le petit souci de réglage qui vont se
régler très vite je vais
prendre les parties
qui faut
et on va on va régler les caméras
j'en ai j'en ai pour un tout petit
instant
il faut que vous me laissiez le temps le
début de Live là c'est
c'est pas simple
du coup où est-ce qu'on a Maxime
est-ce qu'on peut avoir mvl ici
peut-être
un échiquier ici son adversaire est-ce
qu'il est déjà connecté ça me séviant
il est connecté
ok ça m'a déplacé les trucs
il va falloir que je décale on voit la
partie qui a commencé
désolé c'est
c'est pas semble ok on est pas mal et
juste le nom a changé donc
c'est sévillons
et ben voilà on a l'air bon
juste un petit peu décalé sa caméra à
lui et pas super bien cadré de base
bon je pense que le raid a marché je
pense que tout a fonctionné dites moi
dans le chat si ça fonctionne donc c'est
une espagnole
dit ouverte à mon avis j'ai pas tous les
noms d'espagnol mais
et il faut que je mette le score du
match voilà c'est ça qui manquait
on avait on a déjà vu cette ouverture
notamment dans la partie eikaru
contre contre
carwana au candidat
FCO puis on prend là ça va reprendre du
cheval mais c'était pas cette variante
c'est pas la variante où il y a le
[ __ ] un F2
donc cette position ça fait quoi ça fait
égalité matérielle donc on va déjà
compter ça
les Noirs ils ont quatre contre trois à
la dame le pion des cinq ça peut être
une force ou une faiblesse dans la
position là ça a encore la théorie hein
ça joue très vite
les blancs ils ont
en fait les Noirs ils ont un pion
central il contrôle mieux le centre mais
d'un autre côté ils ont pas beaucoup de
socle pour leur pièce on sent la colonne
qui peut être fragile pour ça que le fou
c'est c'est décalé et globalement sans
l'option F7 le rock peut devenir faible
aussi
donc il y a ces deux choses là
qui peuvent
qui peuvent être en faveur de Maxime
après
séviant il a il a le contrôle du centre
avec le pion des 5 et il a peut-être de
l'activité le long de la colonne F après
un coup comme fou c'est 5 admettons
cavalier 4 il peut essayer d'utiliser le
socle en E4 conféré par l'option des 5
pour attaquer à la loi
donc est-ce que Maxime est mieux
franchement j'en sais rien est-ce que la
position est jouable et donne des
perspectives aux blancs oui clairement
après la position donne aussi des
perspectives au noir donc on est sur une
position compliquée ça me fait bien
c'est un joueur américain il doit
maintenant avoir un peu plus d'une
vingtaine d'années depuis le temps qu'on
le voit sur le circuit mais il a fait
partie des jeunes joueurs extrêmement
talentueux qui a pas forcément percé au
meilleur niveau mais je vais aller
regarder sur 2700 ch à mon avis il est
quand même
assez bien classé mondialement
peut-être qu'il est plus à 200700 mais
il a été
il fait un peu des allers-retours
séviance Samuel
il a 21 ans actuellement
il est à 26 84 il a perdu quelques
points après il fait pas une carrière de
joueur professionnel
fait partie un peu de ses joueurs
américains
qui perce pas jusqu'au bout quoi au
final
et au classement mondial du coup il est
54e ça me séviant mais comme je vous
disais il joue plus trop en longue c'est
plutôt un joueur de rapide et en rapide
je le mettrai plutôt aux alentours de la
30e place mondiale
très très très bon blitzer joueur
réellement dangereux qui va poser
beaucoup plus de problèmes à Maxime qui
tourne Zaga contre qui Maxime était
vraiment facile et ça se sent dans
l'attitude de Maxime qui l'a semble
nettement plus concentré on c'est du 15
plus 2 c'est une cadence qui convient
relativement bien à Maxime
on dirait max Lagarde c'est vrai qu'il a
un petit air de Max Lagarde ouais mais
ça vient peut-être de la forme des
lunettes
et même dans le style c'est un petit peu
max Lagarde on a un poil plus fort quand
même
ça me séviant un joueur à un joueur
tactique
dans le face-à-face un joueur qui doit
plutôt convenir à Maxime
mais c'est pas
c'est pas dit qu'il le domine
facilement en fait si Maxime
n'est pas bien réveillé dans le match et
qui commet un moment donné une gaffe ou
quoi ça me séviance un joueur qui est
vraiment capable de tirer profit de
l'erreur et après de s'accrocher c'est
un match qui est réellement possible de
perdre
c'est genre un maximum moins fort ou un
Maxime qui aurait pas décidé de suivre
sa carrière aux échecs mais
il y a pas un tel écart de niveau pour
que Maxime soit en chaussons dans ce
match
là je pense que la question qui se pose
c'est bien c'est des quatre en fait
puis on prend cavalier prend faut
prendre peut-être prendre F3 prendre F3
disons et prendre des 4 genre ça c'est
clairement une question
visuellement je serais bien rentré
dedans avec les Noirs mais ça peut être
très dangereux sur le rock genre tout
radin et est-ce que tu peux aller
calculer si B2 marche
ok là l'ordi trouver un truc
extraordinaire vous prend H7 que Maxime
va trouver s'il est dans cette position
sur cavalier prend il y a Dame des cinq
dames français 5 et sur roi prend il y a
dame F5 va me prendre C5
mais après quand bien même ici ce serait
pas clair qui défend F2 en plus
ce serait pas fini mais les noirs sont
moins bien le roi et tropé le soleil ici
il manque les Punto devant et ça peut ça
peut aller très vite donc ça c'est une
variante en fait on peut arriver à Dame
pro B2
regardez des coups je sais pas moi comme
tout redeuse dire je fais dames C3 tour
des trois Damas et ça va tenir
après à vrai dire ça fait peur ça me
rappelle ça me fait penser une partie
nvldh que Maxime avait fini par perdre à
cause d'une gaffe mais où il était
complètement gagnant
comment tu as de 26 80 et 27 c'est pas
pro bah tu as des joueurs qui sont
tellement doués qu'ils arrivent à 26 80
très jeune et qui décide de faire leurs
études par la suite c'est un petit peu
comme si la goutage qui est
en train de rentrer dans le top 20
mondial petit à petit à 17 ans il disait
ouais bah au final balex des échecs je
fais autre chose il y a Agatha camps qui
avait fait ça d'ailleurs
qui avait arrêté les échecs pour faire
ses études
alors plus dans un deuxième temps mais
c'est comme si un joueur comme c'est
Vian
décidé du jour au lendemain d'arrêter
pour
pour faire autre chose de sa vie mais
qui continue à jouer sur son temps libre
et ben voilà s'il joue à 27 20 25 30 en
étant pro
à 100% voire même 27 40 il va pas tomber
trop bas non plus hein
donc il a pris trois cavaliers prend le
3 il va probablement jouer fois H5 et
full B3
mais ça va gagner le pion pour Maxime je
sais pas trop ce qu'il prévoit de faire
sévion il a réfléchi relativement
longtemps
et Maxime peut peut-être éventuellement
aller taper ce pion des cinq en force
difficile de juger vraiment
de l'évaluation de la position
en tout cas Maxime à 5000 6 minutes
d'avance c'est Vian qui a l'air assez
dubitatif
il a pas l'air de trouver le cours
ça peut vraiment mettre maximum
confiance à de gagner cette première
partie ça fait une énorme différence
bien évidemment
quand on est favoris d'un match et qu'on
et qu'on tape directement avec les
Blancs
ça met quand même dans de très bonnes
conditions après attention il faudra
rester méfiant quand même et pas jouer
aussi facile que contre
l'espagnol et turisaga d'origine
Venezuela au premier tour
Maxime là qui hésite entre reprendre en
C3 ou prendre en G4 en premier
on va voir
car les projets 4 est quand même
intéressant ouais c'est ce que j'étais
en train de me dire parce que ça vient
me prendre le fou et le fou va avoir la
liberté de taper sur deux diagonales et
il peut faire des allers-retours sur
l'une ou l'autre
ça fait mal là quand ça fait des
allers-retours rapides comme ça
ça peut mettre ça me séviant au supplice
là maximil a l'air de jouer de manière
beaucoup plus sérieuse qu'au premier
tour
ouais on voit assez vieux le langage
corporel est terrible on sent qu'il suit
quand même
on sent qu'il suit
il fait Dame des trois d'ailleurs
immédiatement fait un petit clin d'œil
au Punto
je vois bien c'est bien en mettre le
Cavaillon F6
mais ça va enchaîner un kg 6 tour D1 ça
arrive de partout à côté français
tellement dur de jouer contre Maxime
quand il est en forme comme ça qui met
les ingrédients qu'il est là dans les
ouvertures
il a vraiment été solide dans le début
aussi Maxime
là il a tout de suite mis une position
difficile à Sam il y a quand même de
belles sommes en jeu il y a 200000
dollars pour
pour le vainqueur du tournoi donc c'est
pas c'est pas rien
et forcément
Maxime va avoir envie d'aller les
chercher
surtout que le tournoi final est à
Toronto donc
en réel
ça donne très envie commence par G6 donc
il s'affaiblit encore un peu plus le roi
il était déjà fait sur case blanc de par
l'absence du pion F7 maintenant il a
faible aussi sur case noire bon il a pas
joué G5
ça vient taper le pion des 5 sur tout
rat D8 il y a dame prend à 6 déjà c'est
un château de cartes là la position de
Sam c'est bien
qui est en train de s'écrouler
il va devoir faire cavalier F6 pour
amener une pièce en défense quand même
c'est ce qui joue et la maxime va
pouvoir aller faire parler peut-être le
pion h
il aurait pas dû laisser se [ __ ] de
casse blanche ça me sévère mais la
position était réellement difficile à
jouer
mais on voit vraiment là que
que Maxime a envie de remporter cette
partie
mais le fou en B3
il se place à gauche il se place à
droite
il joue il joue fort
il joue fort notre Maxou
avec des pièces en bois je sais pas
comment ça se passe à Montréal mais en
tout cas les joueurs seront
au même endroit dans le même lieu pour
jouer
tu veux un scarifier pour ton manteau je
crois que c'est le Final Eight Toronto
j'espère pas dire de bêtises
corrigez-moi dans le chat
de mémoire c'est le final light mais
après j'ai pas relu des fois ça change
les règlements
je suis jamais sûr d'avoir lu le dernier
règlement officiel ou les règlements au
cours là on imagine que Maxime va
enchaîner par cavalier G5 pour
éventuellement faire cavalier aussi
toucher la tour et la chasser
C4 aussi possible aussi possible moi je
partirai plus sur cavalier G5 et une
faiblesse je vais pas très envie de que
les Noirs s'en débarrassent après ces
quatre ça a l'air aussi extrêmement fort
sur pion prend il y a dame prend sa
touche et sur ces quatre des quatre il
y a ok
me gênera un petit peu
cavalier j'ai 5 qui regarde peut-être
tourbé 8 qui pourchasser le fou mais bon
pierre juste fois deux hein
il fait ces quatre alors il a dû trouver
un truc qui gagne sur des quatre que
j'ai raté
après ça doit probablement gagner parce
que D4 on peut même faire ces cinq rois
bouger car rédiger 5 ouais bon
c'est trop en fait il y a trop de pièces
qui conversent sur le roi à Sam c'est
bien une position
désespérée Maxime qui fait vraiment
parler la poudre
de poudre ispaking comme comme disent
les Anglo-Saxons sur leur live
donc on imagine peut-être un cavalier à
5 alors comme autre idée défensive
avec l'idée d'essayer de supprimer ce
fou pour un peu respirer niveau roi
voilà la position est vraiment
dramatique là pour séviant
beaucoup trop de pièces sur son rock
c'est dur pour pour Sam
il est en train de se faire un VLD bon
il suit simplement bon il a envie de
chialer là c'est bien
il y a peut-être qu'un sur cavaliers à 5
aussi ouais il y a tout en fait
d'ailleurs cavaler à 5 x 2 on menace
peut-être dame C3 double attaque qui est
assez rare de pouvoir double attaquer
des chevaux comme ça sans qu'il puisse
se protéger
terrible
ouais non ça c'est terrible
ça c'est une déchirures
il est pas bien
ça ouais mais 4 dames C3 non
double attaque aussi
ça sent il y a rien qui va dans la
position noire ici
ma Maxime qui a vraiment pris le match
au sérieux ça sent dans son attitude
et il est extrêmement facile
plus que 3 minutes pour Sam c'est bien
il y a même pas de suspense
se fait chier là
ramenez-nous des adversaires de poids
c'est trop
c'est trop facile
après attention de pas de pas se
relâcher dans la deuxième partie de bien
assurer
petite droite avec les noirs et on
essaye de terminer le match au blanc
ça sort le gif bon là ça peut
sortir le gif à tout moment
ah non là c'est trop dur c'est trop pour
ça
c'est beaucoup trop même pas de suspense
on a même pas le temps de
suer en plus c'est 11 minutes 30 contre
2 minutes
à l'écart de niveau est trop important
Sam ça sent qu'il avait même pas envie
de venir à la Game c'est trop fort en
face
il a l'air désespéré c'est
c'est pas qu'il a l'air c'est qu'il est
désespéré
ça reçoit des trucs bon ça mène ça mène
le courrier côté patronne
ça mène le courrier
bon
postd
un tel format est vraiment l'avantage ce
Maxime bah le truc c'est que Maxime est
juste nettement plus fort que c'est bien
qui est très fort
bam C3 cavalier prend B3 dame prend F6
bon ça aussi l'air sympa toche un
cavalier complètement en jeu le pion
dessin
2 j'ai même pas l'idée des Noirs alors
l'ordi qui veut dame prend à 4
ok apparemment
dame de tout 8 ok donc l'idée c'est fois
deux d'en prendre un 4 de séviant
c'est pas une
pour Maxime va le voir le dame prend à 4
du coup il va hésiter entre ses prendre
et 5 et dames C3
il y a aussi camaïeu 5 intermédiaires
qui donne envie à vrai dire
et ça est-ce qu'il y a un piège non pas
de piège
genre
d'être le coup
dame ces trois cavalier prend dame
prends M6 ça a vraiment l'air d'être le
coup facile
pour se retrouver avec un pion de plus
mais bravo assez viande qui trouve
la possibilité qui donne la possibilité
à Maxime de se tromper donc ça c'est
réellement bien joué et dames ces trois
jouets évidemment trop facile
beaucoup trop facile pour Maxime
et d'un point F6
et il menace maintenant des
immédiatement tout recettes à me G7 mat
et surtout au 8 il va simplement pouvoir
encaisser un premier Punto
et il va garder la taxe et aussi ce pion
assise qui va rester en ligne de mire
pour pour le joueur français
avec aussi du H4 H5 qui peut partir qui
est vite le match du couloir et qui
donne de
l'espace à l'ailer le roi et de
l'attaque au blanc plus qu'une minute 20
pour Sam c'est bien
allez trouve au moins un coup de défense
histoire de nous faire un peu vibrer Sam
tu as 8 il essaye
ma mère
[Musique]
ça parle de des joueurs d'échec en
surpoids il y en a on pense
immédiatement à Yann et pomyachi qui va
peut-être être champion du monde d'ici
quelques mois
donc on prend des cinq
c'est déjà un pion de plus pour Maxime
et le roi de séviant qui est toujours
faible à entouré par les pièces blanches
ce cavalier mal placé la tour mal placée
le pion mal placé et les blancs qui vont
jaillir ils tentent
que s'il a un pion moi-même les finales
sont perdantes et l'idée de prendre un
punto ici c'est que au moins si on
survit on n'est pas perdant
mais bon tu vas pas survivre qui va
mieux 5 bloque les cases de retrait de
la dame on menace déjà du dame F7 roi je
suis et suivant où sera la dame il peut
y avoir des cavaliers G6 si tu reprends
il va peut-être tenter un cavalier C5
mais ça devrait pas durer très longtemps
notamment déjà juste à me mettre set
dame C7 qui fait
qui refait pion de plus avec le pion D
qui avance
il fait cavalier des 4
est-ce qu'on a un coup comme cavalier G4
presque mais cavaliers G4 il y a
cavalier 2 package ça menace ce matin
qui fait mat donc c'est un petit
subterfuge pour tenir
après Maxime peut juste faire de la même
cette dame C7
ça gagne un pion et ça donne le plan des
6 des 7 et 8
c'est simple mais diablement efficace
ça c'est le coup facile j'ai envie de
dire pour Maxime
bah cette dame c'est 7 c'est le coup
facile
ça c'est simple après
je pense que même juste H4 ça a l'air
bien aussi quand même après il veut
faire peut-être cavalier ou deux mais
bon roi H1
hier
il y a absolument R
bon
on va voir comment il joue Maxime et il
y a tout il y a tout qui gagne ici
il y a tout qui gagne pour Maxime
après il doit chercher un truc qui
termine vraiment la partie de type
cavalier projet si ils sont un truc
comme ça mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a souvent du cavalier 2 qui permet de
couper la connexion entre les tours il y
a jamais tout reprendre au 2 il y a dame
prend un donc il faut faire roi H1 âgé
d'âme G6 et ça ça doit être gagnant mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a pas un gain
simple net et sans bavure
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on puisse juste
terminer la partie
en force
malheureusement
pour Maxime
on va repartir on va repartir sur la
partie
donc je pense qu'il va juste faire d'un
F7 à me prendre ces 7
ça paraît être l'option
privilégiée
c'est ce qui fait dans F7
il va faire dame français 7
donc
à mon avis
il y a pas de couilles il y a pas grand
chose à dire trop facile c'est pions de
plus c'est l'attaque il y a tout en fait
il y a absolument tout
dans cette partie
voilà il peut faire juste dame B7
cavalier F7 cavalier 6
il y aura plus qu'à aller au de retour
il y aura
il fait tout rêve 8
menace rien absolument rien
Maxime qui reste quand même concentré
c'est bien c'est bon signe
mais peut-être qu'il faut faire juste
des six pour 17 c'est ce qui fait
là ça menace qui va aller prendre des un
d'ailleurs dame Descartes aussi je suis
déconcentré désolé
c'est trop facile en fait des 6 des 7
des Français 8 et maintenant dame de M6
dame 6 dames C8 facile
ça doit être la manière la plus facile
de gagner mais Maxime concentré
jusqu'au bout il vérifie qui est pas de
pas de magouille cavalief de roi G1
et il a dû vouloir vérifier qui est pas
un dame Descartes elle a juste Dame des
7 échec professionnel
échange les dames et termine la partie
de manière assez
direct impressionnant
bon ça fait un zéro pour max
on n'a pas su à partir du riz beaucoup
plus longtemps que ce que je pensais
on va voir Fabiano peut-être une seconde
on va laisser les câbles sur Maxime
parce que ça peut être un match
intéressant contre
rose et edwardo Martin sale Cantara
c'est un beau joueur
j'ose pas
donc là c'est
Fabi avec les Blancs allez on peut
essayer de se mettre les cames
je peux avoir les cames
OK
on va quand même mettre j'ose même parce
que c'est de ce nom là qu'on le connaît
vous le connaissez sous le nom de
jospermes
intéressant de voir de voir j'ose pas me
la contrainte contre un carwana
il y a pas eu grand il y a même pas
d'envolat à voir parce que c'est c'est
facile c'est simple c'est précis côté
nouvelles
Alcantara qui a un joueur extrêmement
dangereux qui est qui avait bien figuré
au America's Blitz il avait terminé je
crois troisième du championnat des des
Amériques en blitz il y avait il y avait
tout le Grand gratin américain avec les
carwana les Nakamura les levons
les dominent 3e dans ton nom comme ça
c'est pas un hasard
un excellent blitzer
[Musique]
rose et Eduardo Martin
qui sont souvent des beaux joueurs très
tactiques
ce sont des joueurs extrêmement
tactiques les péruviens
qui sont pas toujours faciles à cerner
ni Fabi la lui qui va peut-être
laisser une nul avec les blancs dans la
première
et ça peut se compliquer après parce que
Martine elle sera deux fois les blancs
et c'est vraiment un joueur dangereux
qui fait peur
alors c'est pas des grandes envolées
hein Martinez ça joue pas les échecs
champagne généralement
c'est solide ça fait pas trop d'erreurs
un petit peu à l'image d'un Géorg
meilleur en quelque sorte en un peu plus
quand même offensif mais il donne un peu
cette impression il y a pas de coup de
génie mais il y a pas beaucoup de fautes
et là il peut aller tenter des dames G6
dame français 6 fois je sais pas si ça
marche mais c'est dans son style d'aller
jouer les petites magouilles à 7 là-bas
ça peut il peut il peut vite être
dérangeant et oui je connais Lionel ah
on s'est beaucoup joué avec jospel je
sais comment il pense
et c'est pour ça qu'il est si difficile
à jouer
parce que ouais il a il a il a des idées
assez malsaines
c'est ce qui le rend difficile à
maîtriser
il est que 2006 bizarre après je pense
que les joueurs périvés ont du mal à
enchaîner beaucoup les tournois
et c'est plus des blitzer dans l'âme
j'ai l'impression les Péruviens on voit
le le joueur qui est dans le pseudo est
terrible sur chaise comme qui qui lui
aussi un joueur
un peu dans le même registre dans le
même style
meilleur maintenant qui joue d'ailleurs
pour l'Uruguay on reste en Amérique du
Sud
on la Fabiano Sala il va pas la gagner
de partie je vous l'annonce
elle va pas la perdre non plus mais foot
couleur opposé peut favoriser l'attaque
mais ici les deux joueurs ont des pions
quand même assez assez bien placé face à
la couleur du foie adverse
mais c'est un rêve un de jouer comme des
joueurs comme ça ils sont tellement
précis il y a tellement peu de fautes
mais là mon avis ça peut juste répéter
croiser un âme c'est un roi de dame F4
je le vois pas jouer à H4 je vois les
joueurs répéter ici
pas beaucoup mieux à faire
ah il souffle quand même j'ose même oh
c'est pas backi ou moi en face c'est
Caruana quand même
ça tape fort
je sais pas s'il y a d'autres joueurs
qui qui ont des parties en cours
il y a cames qui aussi qui joue mais
j'ai l'impression que en tout cas moi
tous les joueurs que j'ai
éventuellement car Mera André Kin etc
ont tous terminé on peut mettre les
résultats alors pour moi c'est très
petit
mais il y a trois matchs
et camsky André King c'est terminé aussi
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas forcément le
résultat
il est pas allemand meilleur alors il
est allemand mais d'origine uruguayenne
en fait il y a que Maxime qui a gagné et
donc maintenant il a il a rejoint
la Fédération uruguayenne des échecs
afin de représenter l'Uruguay avec qui
il a joué aux Olympiades d'ailleurs il
avait failli faire nul contre
on va mettre on va déjà se mettre du bon
côté contre Karl saigne il avait raté
car la nul contre Carlson n'a pas grand
chose donc on va remettre blanc du coup
ça va être sévillant
les Noirs ça va être mvl
nul avec les Noirs contre Fabi ah bah
oui il prend évidemment
ouais quand tu es un peu derrière dans
ces matières genre par exemple imaginons
que Maxime le match mvl c'est bien et je
pense qu'à moins d'écart entre
entre j'ose pas mais Carana contre mvlc
viande encore que ça se discute mais
imaginons que Maxime est fait nul dans
cette première partie avec les Blancs le
match est tout de suite très chaud en
fait
pour moi ils étaient pas connectés pour
moi ça jouait pas en fait
André Kim je voyais pas ouais bon peu
importe mais en tout cas match nul
d'accord
en fait ça devient très vite très chaud
il suffit dans la première
de laisser un peu échapper un demi point
et ça devient instantanément très
difficile
donc après
comme ça
on va avoir on va on va attendre
[Musique]
on va attendre la prochaine partie je
sais pas quand ça commence j'ai pas j'ai
pas l'info mais ça devrait rapidement
reprendre
j'imagine en tout cas
en tout cas j'imagine
la mère de Meyer et uruguayen
je crois que meilleur
je crois que meilleur est juif en fait
sa mère est juive je crois
je veux pas dire de bêtises là dessus
je suis pas forcément sûr de
l'information
mais ça parler de Niman même sur sur BFM
c'est beau
c'est magnifique en fait
on va attendre que ça reprenne
déjà du monde oh bah oui mvl il était
dans les meilleurs de sa catégorie je
sais pas si j'ai un follow d'ailleurs
sur Maxime je veux pas rater le début de
la partie je vois pas d'infos sur quand
ça va recommencer
non si j'ai un suivi on va on va
attendre
on va attendre que ça reprenne
on s'en fiche un peu d'argent non parce
qu'il y a des gens qui disaient machin
en Amérique du Sud
c'est pour ça que je disais non en fait
meilleur d'après ce que je sais
sa famille a plutôt trouvé refuge entre
guillemets
en Uruguay c'était par rapport à ça
je crois que sa mère était de confession
juive
c'était en rapport avec ça
c'était en rapport avec cela
on attend que ça reprenne on peut pas
faire grand-chose d'autre
là on n'a pas trop le choix
que d'attendre
complexe
le centre des médias ouais
c'est le plug le plug anal
qui fait très plaisir
est-ce qu'on pense que il a vraiment
inséré un plug non non
non mais bon c'est
des choses qui sont possibles pour ça
toujours pas repris
allez ça y est ça reprend enfin
il a fait des quatre ça me séviant
on va voir ce que Maxime joue avec ce
qui décide de jouer un gambidame
accepter ou est-ce qu'il faut agrumfeld
ça part pour une fête côté Maxime
là il va pas faire la Turbo nul
évidemment
tu vois c'est juste en tout cas
meilleure origine non mais je crois
vraiment que
que c'est ça l'histoire avec meilleur
après à vérifier mais je crois vraiment
ouais c'était juste pour pour rectifier
le chat peu importe c'est une Feld
il y a les pions C3 et D4 donc ils sont
fragiles là ça doit être c'est prend
prise Darma 5 échecs je crois et
peut-être aussi ceci qui existe on fait
confiance à Maxime qui est le meilleur
spécialiste de greenfeldom au monde
et ça devrait il fait Damas 5 alors
ça va probablement être rock ici
ça va probablement être rock côté
séviant et sur dame français 3 peut-être
des cinq peut-être tourner un tour
français 5 pardon je vous dis des
bêtises donc ouais il est pas comestible
il y a thoursin et du coup la dame qui a
pas gagné de tempo sur échec attention
maximum
on sait qu'il a tendance quand c'est un
peu trop facile à légèrement lever le
pied
il va pas falloir
il va pas falloir jouer trop facile
pour des 8 peut-être qui va y avoir
du des sincoder cinco il veut sûrement
vous penser 3
pour C1 et revenir
genre de position qui peuvent être très
très dangereuses
donc il met la pression sur les pions
quand même Maxime
c'est le genre de position où il est
tellement fort alors attendez
non il y avait un problème de caméra
c'était rien
ça m'a mis un petit coup de pression
il a joue mieux que ce vide là est-ce
que je pense Maxime la grue une felda
oui il est
Maxime dans les Green moderne avec une
éponyashi peut-être ce sont les deux
plus grands spécialistes de l'ouverture
au top niveau
après ils en sont tous les deux un petit
peu revenu quand même en longue n'est
pas bien si le premier et Maxime est
quand même en train de modifier
d'élargir son répertoire avec les
gambidas acceptés et ça c'est sûrement
dû au fait que Alpha zero attaque
beaucoup plus le rock
et donc que ça rend
la grue Feld beaucoup plus difficile à
jouer
les cannes doit être inversé ouais
ah mais c'est parce qu'on s'est mis côté
Maxime et que le design n'est pas fait
pour
donc on va se mettre côté blanc
on va se mettre côté blanc après c'est
sympa aussi de se mettre côté blanc pour
voir les positions de l'autre côté il
faudrait que je fasse un truc pour
pouvoir changer noir et blanc
complètement merci merci le chat dans sa
change pas la position
c'est plus c'est plus échiquier qui
était tourné du mauvais côté
donc ouais ça me séviant
qui est en train de
je pense qu'il réfléchit à dessiner
trois tours C1 tu donnes un pion mais tu
tapisses tu tapes là tu gagnes du
développement
et là tu menaces déjà quelque chose
comme d'hab B3 puis on prend ses 6
puisque tu gagneras un temps sur le fou
et sur Fougères il y a tout reprend ses
5 peut-être
Maxime jouerait ça est entré de la
défendre mais ça tu sais avec les Blancs
que tu es mieux
donc des cinq Maxime va pas pouvoir
aller croquer le pion et sur cavaluer 5
on peut peut-être échanger fou prendre
et même un coup comme tour B1
tapissime tu laisses le pion C3 mais tu
veux aller jouer pour F4 F5 F4 5 et le
jeu a le droit ça ça tombe ça semble
dangereux
il fait fouder deux bon fout des deux
c'est trop en fait trop mou comme coup
ah c'est bien qui prend pas sa chance
pas assez dynamique
c'est pas assez dynamique comme coup il
avait l'opportunité vraiment de
d'essayer de gagner un temps et profiter
que Maxime et pas fait CD d'amassin
échec pour essayer d'aller gagner un
tempo sur
sur
sur la position logique
mais là c'est pas le cas
et sur E6 peut-être sur aussi il y a pas
C4 non Maxime peut faire aussi en fait
pour bloquer l'avancée des pions
OK
est-ce qu'on a une idée pour Maxime
bon les coups ça peut être aussi ça peut
être dames et 7 pour sortir de vis-à-vis
à la con là
B6 j'y crois pas j'ai l'impression qu'on
va se prendre des 5 C4 ou un truc comme
ça mais bon mais si j'aime pas du tout
la dame est
dans un coin là elle revient plus après
mais après moi joueur de ce scandinave
j'ai envie de mettre la dame en C7
j'aurais dame c'est ça ici je pense il
fait aussi ouais c'était l'autre coup
après j'ai du mal à évaluer un truc
pareil
genre ça qu'est-ce que ça vaut j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plus de cases
noires et qu'on a plus de pièces en
défense je pense qu'après C4 D5 on peut
pas aller prendre la cale et Maxime sur
C4 damasis des 5 va jouer cavalier des 4
qui prend des quatre il faut prendre des
4 mais fais attention même un coup comme
fouet 3 ici c'est chiant parce que vous
prend un dame prend un ça c'est
typiquement le genre de position qui
peuvent très mal tourner
menace vous prend ces cinq menaces
d’amel 6 fois H6 qualité de moins mais
mes gros jeux évidemment c'est pas G5 ça
c'est un mix clic donc C4
bon disons damassi
après dame C7 est possible des cinq
quand même
et il faut prendre un dame prend j'y
crois pas trop pour Maxime mais
peut-être cavalier des quatre car elle
prend des quatre fous prend des quatre
tours B1
je préfère y jouer ça avec les Blancs je
vais pas vous mentir mais peut-être ça
va
autant ça va
mais c'est clairement une option
pour pour Samuel
il fait ces quatre
jamais tu prends la cale on nous dit
dans le chat ouais je pense je pense pas
non plus c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
de prendre cette qualité
tu vas avoir une cale de plus mais
tu vas suer
mais tu vas grandement tu es
c'est un vrai problème
donc il a fait ces quatre et des cinq
comme prévu à j'ai envie de dire
cavalier des quatre ok il a pas pris la
qualité comme prévu
et du coup l'ordi est confiant il donne
quasiment égal
donc c'est plutôt
plutôt bien parti quand même c'est bien
le fout des deux c'est un coup en trop
pour avoir un temps de plus avoir le
fond E3 qui interdisait cavalier des 4
donc ça semble pas
il fait tourcer un
décalage
alors là c'est aussi un faux amis ça
revient un peu sur le cours de cette
Mazet hier soir cavalier prend E2 c'est
pas forcément la bonne idée parce que
les blancs on les on les pions sur casse
blanche on n'a pas forcément envie de
prendre le fou ici même si on pourrait
continuer par B5 essayer de tout faire
péter mais normalement c'est pas trop
l'idée
et Tours C1 c'est un coup en fait c'est
une double prophylaxie déjà il s'enlève
de la diagonale quand même parce qu'un
jour ou l'autre il aurait pu se faire
manger et aussi après ed il veut faire
céder vous voyez mais déjà un vis-à-vis
entre la tour et la dame c'est pour ça
qu'il est parti sur C1 et sur les idées
comme B5 quand il prendra la tour tapera
sur sur C5 donc c'est une double des Sam
qui est quand même beaucoup plus dans la
partie que
la qualité en disant madame chaude
peut-être mais
complexe
une tour c'est un OK
j'aurais horreur de jouer cette position
avec les Noirs je serai incapable de
jouer un coup Maxime qui fait baisser
genre un truc aussi bête que cavalier
prend alors CD j'y crois pas du tout le
pion est trop bizarre vous prend fou ces
trois disons E5 pour se fixer vous prend
des quatre peut-être maintenant céder et
F4 me terrorise
ce ce trident de pion me
donne la chair de poule
mais après Maxime il va sûrement trouver
une manière de l'arrêter
après maxime a un joli tapis
avec cette victoire à la première onde
ça tranquillise quand même et c'est vrai
que si il place un contre et qui gagne
ici il termine le match quasiment
j'ai même envie de dire quoi
qui réalise
une belle performance dans cette
compétition il m'a dit qu'il avait
vraiment envie d'aller chercher une
calife Maxime
il a vraiment envie d'aller chercher
le top 8 à Toronto pour la grande finale
avec les 200000 dollars c'est quand même
pas rien cette somme de 200000 dollars
juste pour les mettre en perspective
sur tout le circuit du Grand chastours
donc dans lequel les joueurs jouent
quatre tournois à la suite des cas
tournois en remportant le circuit et en
faisant des résultats exceptionnels à
lire et zafiruja a pris la somme de 270
mille dollars
et donc il a joué quatre tournois pour
ça et la très très bien performé au
cours de ces quatre compétitions ici sur
sur cette compétition internet il faut
gagner 5 4 matchs pour pour arriver dans
la phase finale aller jouer quatre jours
en réel 5 jours en réel derrière et il y
a 200000 dollars à la clé donc c'est
quand même une somme très conséquente
pour les échecs pour aussi peu de jours
entre guillemets de compétition pour en
tout 9 jours de compétition
c'est le quart de ce que demande à un
grand chef tour et ça rapporte quasiment
autant
et donc la variante qui arrivait dans la
partie c'est celle dont je vous parlais
donc le fou qui vient en C3 et ouais la
position est dure ça pour moi le
problème c'est ce pion dessin que je
trouve insupportable juste pour vous
illustrer il faut prendre pour prendre
puis on prend disons et prend regardez
ça comment ça avance et comparé avec les
pions noirs j'espère que vous ressentez
le truc mais en fait ça va très très
vite côté blanc et c'est très difficile
à mettre en mouvement côté noir et quand
bien même ça avance c'est beaucoup moins
grave parce que côté blanc ça avance
proche du roi donc F4 5 on peut même
penser après à F5 ou E6 ou D6 c'est bon
après F4 5D 6 fois ça ça paraît
tentaculaire
Maxime qui a fait prend des 5
directement
Sam qui va reprendre du pion c'est
attention à la partie dangereuse
Maxime qui met peut-être des pièges vous
prend des quatre peu donner envie aussi
mais il veut une prise en E4 le Fou est
cloué et sur un coup comme foue 5 il y a
pas tout reprendre parce qu'il y aurait
faut prendre ces 7 mais l'idée de Maxime
c'est Dame E7 qui maintient l'attaque du
Fou et attaque la dame endéen oh là là
c'est ça le ça
très difficile à voir le dame 7 de
Maxime ça c'est un gros gros piège de
Maxime qu'est-ce que c'est marlou
qu'est-ce que c'est marlou côté Maxime
c'est très puissant
cette idée est très puissante et ça va
faire perdre du temps à ça ici
il a joué ses prends des seins qu'il a
vu le dame cette prise C3 prise C3
bon et là pour moi la position blanche
c'est une position de rêve
Maxime encore une nouvelle fois en
difficulté sur sa greenfeld
on se rappelle qu'il avait aussi perdu
lors de du
Grand Prix feed contre contre rapport
avec les noirs
Maxime plus aussi serein qu'avant sur
sur la gruned lui qui était quasiment
intouchable en 2017-2018 sur cette
ouverture
rarêter les joueurs qui qui
réussissaient à le faire ne serait-ce
que vaciller
mais voilà est venu la période covid est
venue alpha zero qui a vraiment rebattu
les cartes de cette ouverture
Maxime qui veut un bloquer
mécaniquement le coup F4 mais là il va
se faire enchaîner par du tout 3 par du
G3 par du F4
ouais ça va être ça va être très très
difficile
Maxime qui sait qu'il est mal ça me
séviant qui a une chance de revenir dans
la partie dans la rencontre
mais voilà il va falloir pour pour Sam
trouver les coûts
et ce coup ça a l'air d'être tout droit
pour protéger le pion à G3 F4 5D 6
cette majorité là d'options c'est deux
pions magnifiques et on voit un même si
Maxime réussissait regardez le nombre de
coups qu'il faudrait pour réussir à
apporter le danger côté noir 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 coups pour réussir à
à peine
créer un semblant de danger alors que ça
va être 1 2 3
et dès le quatrième coup de poussée de
pion les blancs réussiront à créer des
menaces violentes sur le roi donc
clairement maxime a un énorme retard
avec sa majorité de pions qu'on pourrait
appeler de silencieuses et là en plus ça
peut juste commencer à envoyer le Punto
en E5 la partie est très difficile
on compte vraiment sur un choc du joueur
américain sur une grosse défense de
Maxime
veux 5 tours 8 G3 Dame des 4 il veut
embrouiller Maxime
5 40% de séviant et ce qui va avoir le
temps de terminer le français
on est quand même confiant quand on a un
joueur d'un calibre du calibre d'un
Maxime
dame C2 aller tours 8 il faut vraiment
réussir à le bloquer ce pion
allez c'est chose faite
et mettre une dame en E5
peut-être c'est bien on va voir un plan
comme tour de un fou F1 G3 F4 pour venir
consolider cet a-t-elle roi et ensuite
réussir à mettre cette marche avant
Maxime sur tourin qui va mettre la dame
au 5 il commence par G3
alors ce qui va sacrifier le pion H3
afin de se mettre en mouvement Sam
ouais en fait il peut sur dame quelque
part même faire Tourer je sais pas
laquelle est la meilleure des deux cases
avec l'idée sur foo prochain d'avoir G4
et il réussit à choper le fou
latéralement et à l'enfermer donc ce
pion H3 est une chimère pour Maxime
alors il le laisse complètement emprise
mais il veut faire 5 avancer Maxime qui
le prend un Maxime si tu lui donnes un
punto c'est toujours pris un Maxime si
c'est pas pourquoi
c'est pas comestible il bouffe et il
voit après et là sur G4 il doit avoir
une idée
farfelue alors est-ce que ces dames
prend F4
ou est-ce que c'est plutôt peut-être
dame c'est 5 qui vient clouer la
tourelle et ça lui donnera le temps de
H5 C4 c'est très bien joué
Maxime qui est en train de faire ça
tambouille
qui a pas réussi à mettre la marche
avant correctement et Maxime qui est en
train de la retourner cette partie
peut-être qu'il faut aller le prendre ce
pion C4 pour lui tu auras C8 dame D4
essayer de combler les cases noires
attention quand même e5d6 mais Maxime
veut essayer de faire un gros blocus sur
casse blanche et il y a un peu moins de
G4 F5 dans le range
Maxime qui a mis les barbelés la dame
qui va venir en D4 impérial
et là alors dis à une idée de marlou
l'ordi veut tourser de pour G4 tours 2
tu reprends le 2 pour ranger 4 oh mais
c'est trop Maxime qui l'a évidemment il
a tous les coups Maxime et c'est pour ça
qu'il est si dur à battre dans danser
greenfeld
même si la position est dure Maxime qui
tente
qui trouve toutes les ressources
dynamiques tous les pièges mais aussi
cinq attention quand même ça avance fort
le fou qui va pouvoir venir en F3
Maxime qui a peut-être tenté fougère
mais il y aura du E6 qui couperait la
connexion entre le fou et la dame
attention à la position reste quand même
très compromise côté français malgré le
gros enchaînement il part de très loin
dans cette partie il faut F3 qui est
jouée on doit pas avoir de dames F5 à
cause de fous 4 fous prends ces deux et
cette tour en C2 et 3 qui semble
quasiment combiné mais qui manque un
tout petit peu de punch pour le moment
pion j'ai trois défendus cette deuxième
rangée qui est juste assez défendue et
attention parce que ça peut parler fort
avec Dieu si ce qui peut partir côté
Samuel
attention 1 attention Maxime de pas se
prendre aussi si la dame venait à
quitter cette diagonale en G4 qui peut
peut-être un jour enfermer le fou ça
peut être dangereux
ça me sévitant encore 4 minutes 14 c'est
un blitzer de renom
habitué au grosses joutes sur Internet
attention il y a de il y a du danger
il y a énormément de danger là pour
Maxime
oh que c'est dangereux même des idées
comme si spion prend G4 pour aller
rendre un Maxime la monnaie de sa pièce
sur les diagonales autour du roi il y a
danger il y a le feu dans la maison
est-ce que ce fou doit pas revenir en F5
peut-être pas il y a peut-être aussi
c'est G4 quand même
quel travail fourni un par cette dame
qui défend le roi et qui attaque de
l'autre côté
magistral en D4
mais faut trouver une idée là Maxime je
fais confiance il va nous sortir quelque
chose peut-être un H5 finalement pour un
peu gagner du contrôle sur sur ces cases
importantes ça me séviant qui est en
train de prendre la confiance c'est en
train de changer le langage corporel de
Sam concentré comme jamais
il est prêt à jaillir tel un frelon ah
ouais là si part en tant que frelon il
peut faire mal
allez on le sent on le sent chaud patate
il est concentré il est dans la cage
il veut frelonner Maxime là
il y a beaucoup de choses là pour pour
Samuel allez Maxime il faut qu'il fasse
le taf
Max qui est serein notamment grâce à sa
victoire en dans la première qui nous
enlève une sacrée pine du pied parce que
sinon on se rendait dans ce match
Maxime cural et blanc à la prochaine qui
a déjà
fait subir le supplice à Sam Sevian qui
va avoir une deuxième cartouche à lui
mettre
mais bon fauteuil 4 pour ton point de
suivi de scission prend aussi 6 ça peut
s'enchaîner sur le roi de Maxime
ça peut aller vite et fort mais il aura
encore tout refué puis on prend aussi
dame prend des cas tu reprends des 4 ce
serait dur à cette finale mais il y a
peut-être un tour Eiffel maintenant
miraculeux à la fin allez je vais
essayer de la montrer la variante elle
est calculée à la main mais non il y a
pas de Tours F2 en fait il y a un punto
ici simplement
je prends mes rêves pour pour des
réalités il y a un punto en F4 mais il y
a peut-être du Tour C8 en décalage pour
Maxime pour aller chercher du Tour
tourner un tour c'est de c'est peut-être
ça l'idée de Maxime oh non il faut
prendre ces deux désolé mais il y a même
fou 4 on prend nos rêves pour des
réalités
de tenir ça
et sur F5 peut-être 7 x 6 la tour qui
débarquerait en C2 pour aller jouer le
perpète c'est ça les idées de Maxime les
idées de défense
ça me sévi en qui envoie aussi son va
probablement voir cette variante sur
l'échiquier le fou qui arrive en E4 qui
débarque le pion à deux qui va tomber et
c'est le pion G6 qui va lui aussi
disparaître de l'échiquier et le pion
aussi se met Maxime qui va
contre-attaquer le long de la deuxième
et le long de la colonne C attention
attention Maxime il va falloir trouver
les bons coups mettre les barbelés ça me
séviant qui s'est laissé un matelas
suffisant pour la terminer de 48 avec
les deux secondes par coup ça pourrait
suffire pour aller au bout attention oh
la maxime faut qu'il nous trouve des
idées dont il a le secret son roi est
tellement en train de crier famine
et on n'arrive pas à connecter un tour
G2 ça suffit pas ça prend à deux ça va
prendre G6 côté Samuel
ça y est il va jouer on voit il a la
main sur la souris on le sent il fait un
décalage allez trompe toi
trompe toi Sam peut-être Maxime qui peut
direct partir en C8 au oui ça c'est pas
une mauvaise idée on y avait pas pensé à
cette tourelle en C8
et oui il y a plus pion prend d’âme
prend tout reprendre c'est bien joué
mais alors il y a du dame F 600 oh dame
F6
ça a l'air méchant quand même il a l'air
méchant Samuel mais plus que de 16 allée
Maxime
il n'y a pas de gain imminent ça
menacera pas puis on prend aussi
oh ça défendu justesse repris de
justesse pour le moment attention aussi
au décalage avec des fouberts qui
pourraient laisser passer la dame il y a
des dames G5 aussi à beaucoup de
décalages mais plus qu'une 58 ça me
séviant qui est en train de prendre dans
son matelas qui en a plus beaucoup sous
le pied il va falloir qu'il joue un coup
ça sera ça va être à mon avis soit dame
5 pour aller dans H5 dame G5 soit d'un
f-6 pour s'approcher de la case F7
allez Sam il faut qu'il fasse une
connerie là
il a pas le coup c'est une bonne
nouvelle il réfléchit il a remis sa main
sur sa tête même ses mains sur sa tête
plus qu'une trente il va être juste là
il va être juste là il y a pas de gain
direct il y a pas de gain direct pour
Sam c'est bien
et ça le fait suer plus qu'une va oh il
a pas de bol là Sam il pourrait il
pourrait y avoir un
il pourrait y avoir rien dire direct il
y ait pas oh il est en train oh il est
en train de souffrir là ouais ça me fait
penser au mur de lui en cyclisme oh 300
400 m là
sur sur les ponts à 20% quand tu as un
Julian la Philippe qui part et que tu es
en train de suer parce que tu peux pas
tu peux pas aller le chercher
et là il est pas bien oh il est pas bien
le pauvre oh c'est pas de bol il
pourrait y avoir gain qui tue la partie
il y a pas il cherche mais il y a pas et
il est en train de se laisser avec 40
secondes oh il peut même la perdre Sam
ça va être du 55 ans cette partie
il fait tout 5 il te choque complètement
en fait
pas quand même ça reste chaud mais il
s'est laissé que 40 secondes Maxime qui
va fermer la porte
attention F5 fou prend pion prend
peut-être du des 6 tours c'est de Maxime
qui a trois vins
il a assez de temps là Maxime pour
réussir à trouver un piège on le voit là
il a affûté oh il a affûté le garçon il
a affûté le Maxime
j'aimerais pas être là à la place de Sam
parce que la centrale de préparer des
pièges qu'on a pas vu depuis un long
moment
oh là là ça va ça va envoyer un Jeff
assez violent donc l'ordi donne fouf 5
comme meilleur coup avec position égale
mais c'est pas forcément ça le coup
qu'on cherche tourgé deux avant roi H1
tours j'ai trois tours géant ou bien
jouer de la part de séviant il Adam
prend géant au jouet tempo quelle
réponse du joueur américain
qui trouve une variante incroyable il
avait prévu il avait prévu le piège de
Maxime c'était son coup mais en fait
défense impressionnante ici du joueur
américain qui retourne la situation la
dame en géant qui va être magnifique
pour lui elle va taper le roi elle va
tout couvrir pour prendre géant d'arme
prends géant dame j'ai 7 tours G5
peut-être ouais F8 mais c'est dur il va
y avoir du fouet 5 du fulpro H3 Maxime
dans la difficulté là là ça me séviant
qui qui enchaîne quelques coups de
boutoir 44 secondes c'est juste mais ça
peut suffire
et lorsque la dame arrive en géant sa
menacera une découverte en 8 avec un
fouet 8 échecs vous prend des sets qui
pourra arriver c'est tomber quand même
pile poil pour Sam là qui a eu un petit
peu de réussite c'est mérité quand même
côté ça me séviance ce petit coup de
pouce du destin
H4 ça paraîtra un bon coup attention la
tour G5 on l'a tourgé 5 qui peut faire
très mal tu en prends j'ai 5 ans j'ai 5
tours c'est un roi H2 bon tour j'ai 5
qui a l'air de tuer la partie simplement
et ce qui va la voir c'est bien ou pas
allez 27 secondes il est dans le dur il
l'a pas pour le moment attends j'ai cinq
et monumental en fait ouais F8 il y a
dans ma chute et il l'a ouais c'est dur
pour Maxime évidemment tours pas
papillon prend qui bloque raie la
colonne mais bien tout reprend tout
retour c'est un échec roche 2 et il y a
même pas de Tours c'est de Maxime qui
est en train de se faire éteindre
il est en train de se faire étendre et
pourtant on en est pas encore aux
pénurie d'énergie mais la SAM séviant
qui a qui a décidé de couper le gaz de
Maxime sous le pied avant l'hiver
oh ça joue très bien ça a été fort là ce
qu'il a fait Samuel
mais attention en plus si le roi parent
F8 on peut faire tourner 6 et à les
taper H3 côté Samuel il y a pas non il y
aurait même pas de de Dame des cinq
échecs plus qu'une 16 pour Maxime allez
il faut encore trouver un piège côté
Maximo 5 c'est un joli coup mais ça doit
perdre de plusieurs manières possibles
mais c'est marlou ça fait suer
a l'air fort Maxime va décaler le roi il
a pas 10000 cases il va pas il peut pas
aller en F8 il y a peut-être juste dame
B4 dont j'ai 8 et dame prend le 7 qui
suffit mais il y a plus que 9 secondes
c'est Vian qui hésitent il fait dame B4
ça va être dame 7 pour Maxime dont j'ai
8 ans j'ai 8 et dame prend E7 eh oui les
tourelles sont ceux des doubles il
réfléchit à quoi Sam plus 3 secondes il
va tomber non il a réussi à jouer Maxime
qui va faire peut-être ton projet 8 t'en
prends j'ai 8 dames prends E7 et sur
fupron F5 il y aura dame G5 dame pro F5
5 secondes 2 avec 2 secondes par coup ça
va largement suffire à Samuel pour
égaliser dans ce match un partout quelle
réponse du joueur américain partie
rondement mener et Maxime une nouvelle
fois en difficulté alors il a peut-être
un piège c'est roi prend ton repenser
trois puis on prend dam prend le 7 tours
c'est un match c'est peut-être le seul
mais c'est bien maigre
Maxime qui abandonne j'aurais peut-être
tenté à sa place c'est ton jamais
ça aurait pu quand même tenter mais
Maxime qui a décidé d'abandonner et à la
surprise générale ça me séviant qui
égalise dans ce match un point partout
ça pour une surprise c'est une surprise
mais quelle partie je vous avais dit
avant le match pas de relâchement contre
ce joueur américain qui peut ainsi les
dans une bonne position être extrêmement
dangereux
et ces choses faites illégalise
Maxime qui a décidé de pas tenter le
piège après qui était quand même
téléphoné mais qui pouvait hein être
tentait on va mettre une petite pub je
vais prendre un truc à manger je vais
couper la cam
le live a été prévu un peu dernière
minute on va se mettre une petite pub
et on va et on va faire un petit
grignotage
de mon côté pour récupérer aussi comme
les joueurs donc je reste avec vous
quand même en vocal
je pense le problème c'était juste pour
prendre
quelle partie quand même
quelle partie incroyable
quelle partie absolument incroyable
très très bien joué de la part de Max de
Sam pardon dans cette partie contre max
je veux voir un petit peu comme je vous
disais j'ai besoin de récup aussi
pour pouvoir vous proposer un
commentaire de qualité
pas le choix
que de proposer un commentaire de
qualité
il a vraiment très bien joué
il a été très bon je pense que dans les
autres matchs
je crois que c'est un partout partout
ce qu'on peut avoir la partie je peux
vouloir passer ouais
il y a peut-être une erreur de caméra on
verra après
sympa comme match en tout cas
même si on est pour Maxime c'est plus
sympa des matchs serrés
en vrai
ça réduite après coup je sais pas
en tout cas beau match
c'est pas moi qui fait le tableau frère
je pense que la prochaine partie est
tellement importante
je reviendrai dans une seconde
en tout cas le match agréable à suivre
le match est très agréable à suivre
première partie très bien menée par
Maxime
qui a gagné assez facilement et deuxième
partie
je trouve aussi très sympa de c'est bien
c'est pas comme des califes candidats ou
quoi ou on s'en fiche un peu on veut
juste que Maxime gagne
enfin on veut juste que Maxime gagne
tout le temps mais je veux dire en fait
un truc pour les candidats
s'il y a une facilement je prends tous
les jours
bon là aussi
mais je veux dire match serré me dérange
moins
des matchs comme confiture c'est pas
intéressant en fait
ça reprend à 30
il se cale sur ma pause repas en fait
c'est sympa
c'est terminé comment mal
il n'y a pas trop de pause entre les
parties
c'est quand même agréable
ça vous trouvez que ça vous dirait qu'on
se trouve un endroit
poursuivre live de championnat du monde
ça repart OK
désolé j'ai mal compris leur truc
je finis juste ce que j'ai dans la
bouche et on se lance dans la
donc je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui est dans le chat qui a trop
de pause dans les tournois parce que là
par exemple on a eu à 10 minutes de
pause c'est moins que ce qu'on aurait
dans un tournoi réel ça rejoint
exactement la même chose
il avait fait pousser cinq fois il a dû
analyser ça me séviant entre les parties
j'imagine
mais il y a une petite modification
Maxime qui a introduit en H3
ok j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont tous les
deux regarder entre
ils connaissent c'est pas très bien
quand ça connaît loin
c'est pas bon signe
c'est terrible il a dû regarder la main
il a tous les coups c'est bien en fait
il y a pas tout reprendre des 4 c'est
important de comprendre à cause de dame
prend des cartes d'âme prend des quatre
cavaliers d'eux donc ça c'est
extrêmement con un important de l'avoir
et c'est sûr vu la vitesse à laquelle il
joue et vu la première partie c'est sûr
que c'est Vian entre les parties la
regarder jusque là
ah ouais non là c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle
après je préfère la jouer avec les
Blancs celle là parce que toujours
l'impression que le roi est faible mais
il y a du contre jeu avec le pion des
côtés noir
très franchement
c'est bien c'est pas cool là qu'il est
pris le dessus dans l'ouverture
parce que je pense que le problème de
Maxime a réglé dans la grumefell est
plus difficile
que celui de séviant
attention maximum en danger en fait dans
ce match nulle rapide
les échecs en cadence rapide justement
cette position là elle joue mais
il était tellement bien
à la sortie de l'ouverture dans la
première partie qu'on aurait pu espérer
qu'il réussisse ça à mettre la tête sous
l'eau de ses viandes
et malheureusement il a pas réussi
donc le score c'est un partout il y a
juste un bug sur
Fouquet ça a l'air d'être un bon coup ça
vient couvrir les casques le cavalier
touche surtout la 4G 2 et ça laisse le
la case à 7
entre les game pourquoi ça fait partie
intégrante du jeu en fait
bon ça je peux pas comprendre en fait
c'est normal de pouvoir regarder la
théorie entre les Game c'est
c'est le cas aussi dans les tournants en
réel c'est toujours le cas c'est
ça permet de faire une réponse à
l'adversaire c'est c'est ça qui fait
évoluer les matchs c'est par exemple les
matchs du championnat du monde
ça joue ça joue une partie par jour et
ça regarde la théorie et ce qui s'est
joué avant c'est aussi ça qui est
intéressant d'aller creuser dans le fond
de la préparation adverse
on va avoir et c'est soit tour C8 pour
jouer la colonne ouverte soit tour à 7
pour essayer de doubler moi je serai
plutôt partisan de tour à 7 parce que ça
donne
plus d'options que je trouve
intéressantes
je comprends pas pourquoi Maxime la
première ligne alors qu'il est fondament
plus fort autant sortir de l'autre la
théorie enfin bon là c'est juste parce
que tu comprends pas le niveau en fait
maxime est notamment plus fort que son
adversaire parce qu'il est plus fort
dans la théorie donc c'est logique
d'essayer de l'attraper dans la théorie
et de prendre l'avantage
on nous propose dame G5 alors dame G5
intéressant comme coupe ce que j'imagine
que ça veut vous prend à 8 tu reprends à
8 dam G4 cavalier prend H3 d'un me prend
H3 d'en prendre des deux
j'aurais jamais fait d'âme j'ai 5
j'ai l'impression qu'il est trop de
problèmes et peut-être juste dame G4
prise prix tour D1 et encaisser le Punto
des 4
je pense c'est vraiment tout à 7 le coup
le coup a joué
après ça se débat avec ton C8
franchement mais mon tour à 7 tu donnes
aussi ton dessin
à voir
qui sont en fait les deux colonnes sur
lesquelles tu vas aller ça te donne même
tout recettes pour 8
et ça te couvre quelques cases proche du
roi je sais pas je ferai vraiment tout à
cet en réflexe
pour moi c'est plus logique
et dame j'ai 5 écoute François Jacques
j'aurais trop peur qu'il y ait une
couille c'est trop
après comment il refuse l'ordi
faut prendre à 8 on reprend à 8
dames ah oui dame F3 qui prend H3 et là
du coup pas d'âme prend H3 que je
regardais de base mais roi F1 et il y a
pas d'arme prend des deux à cause de
dame prend à 8 mat
il a fait tour à 7 ouais
tempo de Maxime alors l'idée c'est que
maintenant il me reste reprend des 4
et sur tour D7 il doit avoir une idée de
marlou
on va regarder ça
sûrement le coup que j'aurais
avec les Noirs tours des 7
des trois quais ultra malin mais dur
ouais [ __ ] c'est hyper dur en fait
c'est hyper dur
et c'est même pas clair parce qu'il y a
de la F3 et bon
c'est hyper dur
la position en fait est pas facile c'est
Détroit le coup c'est hyper dur
et je pense qu'il va faire tourner cette
alors il fait j'ai trois du coup là
dessus et sur cavalier aussi s'il envoie
il va faire tourcer un il va envoyer F4
il va prendre l'espace il couvre et
ouais ça peut être très vite très dur
Maxime qui a l'air de paniquer sur un
truc mais je sais pas
pour moi des trois est trop dur
ces viandes qui est dans son match un
truc est-ce qu'il y a d'autres comme
coup
il va
je pense pas qu'il est Détroit d'âme des
quatre tours F7 c'est très dur c'est
très très dur après
surtout très risqué parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont ratables
cavaliers aussi ouais
ça force du puzzle le problème c'est que
le pion isolé il est bloqué
voilà c'est en train de tourner pour
Maxime en fait parce que le roi noir il
est plus faible et le pion des quatre il
met pas vraiment de marche avant
bonne question
en fait si tu veux en H1 tu menaces pas
H3 j'ai 3 pardon
donc il est droit c'est de protéger le
pion
dommage 5 pour Maxime
position est vraiment complexe
sur cavalier G5 il doit avoir une idée
là ça joue vraiment bien
il doit juste vouloir foudre et menacer
F4 ou H4 vraiment fort là
le niveau de jeu est très très venu
et surgit six vous prend cavalier F4 il
a dame 5
de passer une énorme séance
assez bien
G6 avec des fous prangés 6 cavalier F4
il y a plus d'un mecs
c'est beau les échecs quand c'est comme
ça pas de G6 direct parce que dame 5 en
fait c'est Dame 5 échecs
le problème
d'am6
ça c'est dur et du coup c'est chèque en
premier pour faire G6 et cut le dame 5
et sur foopranger 6 cavaliers F4
c'est jouer par Sam c'est bien
ah ouais c'est costaud
très très costaud de la part de Sam
je pense que Maxime va faire j'ai trois
quoi que
j'ai trois tu te laisses un peu de
fragilité sur F2 tu peux revenir en G1
pépère le chat
OK
position est très très compliqué il y a
peu de pièces sur les chéquiers en tout
cas la position assez ouverte assez
dynamique mais c'est c'est dur à jouer
d'en croiser un G6
c'est sûr qu'il va l'avoir G6
c'est sûr que ce sont une idée en fait
et vous voyez cette tour à 7 je vous
disais elle peut être utile sur la 7e en
fait dans cette ligne là elle est hyper
utile parce que ça empêche d'apprendre
cette mat en quelque sorte
même pas en quelque sorte mais de
manière très directe
donc là pour le moment le roi blanc est
en échec c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas
faire mate en un
j'ai 3 G6 et sur un et surtout ranger 6
là dessus c'était cavalier F4 quand même
je suppose et le problème c'est que sur
pion prend dame prend il y a la tour en
des deux qui en l'air pour vous
expliquer tous les tous les problèmes de
la position
Dame des cinq l'idée c'est Dame prend
fou prendre touche le cavalier on pourra
peut-être prendre des quatre ah mais
même pas
de façon il a pas pris il a fait il a
fait tourner 7 qui est plus logique
un des cinq tours c'est un cavalier 5
cavalier F3 il échange tout alors ça a
cliqué vite cette variante maintenant
est-ce que on peut prétendre à quelque
chose
râger 2 disons parce que c'est logique
ça touche la tour ça protège tomber 3
tours
je sais pas c'est ça reste ultra complet
ça reste ultra complexe
maxime a fait tours C4
donc il va y avoir tourbé 3 c'est joué
par Sam
ça va
non c'est nul
ok le pion qui va venir en Détroit ok
Maxime veut jouer quand même un truc
intéressant
très marlou
évidemment Sam c'est bien la vue
très très malin de la part de Maxime une
nouvelle fois
c'est incroyable le niveau qui s'envoie
donc probablement roi G7 pour les Noirs
directs
mais là l'ordi donne gagnant au blanc à
cause de F4 G4 qui arrive
elle est pas si simple
il a fait des trois rois G2
il a fait des trois
il veut quoi il veut roi F3
disons roager 7 3 E3 disons H5 tour des
tout réussis
roi F3 est heureux
ça va être chaud
hyper intéressant une nouvelle fois
là pour le moment la tour a plus de 15
mais on n'a pas d'accès à cette tour
parce que en fait le seul accès qu'on a
c'est celui-là
ce qu'on peut y aller
genre on envoie un plan comme ça roi et
fin roi des un roi LC1 roi B1 roi à deux
ça paraît long mais en fait tu fais quoi
avec les noirs
c'est une vraie question c'est pas une
blague
en fait c'est quoi c'est un deux trois
quatre cinq six coups
ok tu fais roi F1 roi G7 roi E1 roi F6
roi D1 disons H5 roi C1 tout réussi roi
B1 2
OK
et encore ça joue prise tout recadre
tu vas quand même avoir un pion plus
mais ça doit être nul mais ça veut dire
que roi F1 c'est pas une tentative
débile
droit F1 est un coup pas proposé par
l'ordi mais c'est loin d'être débile
pas proposé par l'ordi mais loin d'être
stupide il fait tout recap Maxime
alors tout recap il veut quoi
je suis en train de réfléchir à tous ces
six ici
si tu prends des deux je prends B3 si tu
prends des trois je prends C2
ouais non c'est c'est trop en fait
mais après ça ça doit quand même rester
nul mais c'est pion de plus
c'est quand même nul mais tapions de
plus et tu presse
d'ailleurs tu peux avoir un plan comme
roi F1 roi E2 roi des un roi c'est un
tour c'est à 5 tours on peut en porte on
se on se gare
peut-être 3 G7 alors
on va voir
elle est pas facile à jouer avec les
noirs
et ta pâte on reprend B2
tu reprends B2
tu reprends des deux tu reprends des
deux tu reprends B4 tour à deux
ok ça doit être nul mais c'est chiant
ouais tu vas faire tout F4 roi F3 est
parti et tu vas couper et protéger ok
donc ça tu as pas
c'est tellement dur à jouer parce qu'il
y a tellement d'options
je pense à faire tout recette Maxime
donc
pour 7 je pense qu'il va partir en H6
mais Maxime va tenter de le réseauter
mais je pense qu'il va partir en H6 et
qui va essayer de partir quand même pour
un roi b2d2 maintenant je pense 3 h si
c'est un bon coup ici pour séviant
après attention parce que H6 F4 tu
reprends B2 tu reprends B2 D2 il y a G4
infernal D1 il y a G5 roa H5 tu reprends
H7 donc ça veut dire que tu peux mettre
cette menace ok qu'est-ce que c'est dur
du coup il a fait rouager 8
ah ouais
le level des deux joueurs est assez
impressionnant est-ce que sur un coup
comme j'ai pas H4 est-ce que tu reprends
B2 fait nul en force ici
j'ai l'impression
pas sûr
ça c'est nul en force et pas trop dur à
faire
Maxime qui a fait H4 et là il y a tout
reprend B2
et c'est nul en force c'est pions plus
pour Maxime mais c'est une nul facile
mais quelle partie encore des deux
hommes là pour la peine là les deux ont
joué fort et bien en même temps et ça
nous offre un sacré spectacle
Sam qui doit partir pour cette finale
Maxime qui le sait mais il met la
pression sur la pendule
pas facile comme décision à prendre mais
bon normalement quand tu peux rentrer
dans le 32
Maxime qui va vouloir peut-être jouer
sur un roi un peu bloqué mais je crois
même pas
ok je m'attends à tout reprendre B2 ici
Maxime qui met la pression mais mais qui
réussir pas à faire rompre Samse
qui nous targue d'un beau spectacle
ouais tu reprends des deux jouets dans
la salle jouer ultra fort alors moi je
calcu les variantes mais je peux les
checks à l'ordi ils ont pas le temps de
chèque à l'ordi donc leur vitesse de
calculer hallucinante
bon c'est le la différence entre 2008 et
3100 je réussis à suivre ce qu'ils font
uniquement parce que j'ai l'air de la
turbinette en fait
sinon c'est ça va trop vite en fait
leur vitesse
est trop grande
leur vitesse est beaucoup trop grande
de bonne partie sera assez mal pour Max
ouais mais après on voit des beaux
échecs
j'ai confiance en mon Maxime
on peut pas capitaliser sur Toral
c'était pas possible ok il veut faire
wash 6 et G4 G5 mais c'est vu par Sam
c'est bien il va essayer de monter le
roi Maxime
ça fait retour prends à 4 tours B3 et je
pense qu'il va faire tout à 7 ici
pour roi G7 H5 professionnel
ouais c'est bien joué
c'est Vian qui est en retard à
l'allumage et Maxime c'est dommage en
cette deuxième partie je vous avais dit
attention c'est pas le même niveau que
il tourne Zaga les baisses de régime
peuvent coûter très cher face un joueur
du calibre de samsevian et ça a pas
manqué il a tout de suite égalisé
derrière il a serré avec les noirs très
bien joué de sa part
c'est la différence ils sont ils sont
ces joueurs sont stratosphériques c'est
une autre il va mettre le rang H6 je
pense c'est bien joué
non c'est
pas faut reconnaître quand on a des
belles parties je vous comprends pas
trop parfois dans le chat
genre moi je suis juste heureux de voir
deux belles parties de trois belles
parties d'échecs jusqu'à maintenant
je trouve ça extrêmement agréable à
suivre
je trouve c'est parti très très agréable
à regarder
quand les deux hommes se répondent
coupent pour coup pour coup
un Maxime qui essaie de tourner mais ça
c'est nul il va essayer de mettre le
rangée 5 et d'une manière X ou Y mais il
pourra pas
Sam solide sur ses appuis et Maxime qui
va être en danger il va avoir les Noirs
dans la quatrième
ça va être très chaud
tu penses qu'il va faire tourber ces 3G
6 allée G5 ouais non c'est complètement
nul
il va y avoir un bain
ah non c'est une belle partie
le message était beau quand même
Maxime qui tente qui essaye de faire
chier jusqu'au bout
c'est bien ce qui fait Maxime
ouais dommage qui était beau vous avez
pas eu le temps de le lire
bah c'est comme toujours
si égalita la quatrième Armageddon je
crois que c'est direct mais allez
est-ce que ça peut craquer côté séviant
non je crois pas
parce que en fait contre le pion G on
peut faire la défense passive
t'as pas vu la fin du message thé vert
il y avait
un gros nul tu puisses rien à rien le
miracle de ta chaîne c'est qu'entre
minable vous êtes de la même race mais
entre joueurs tu n'es qu'un comique
trier bon c'était magnifique comme fin
de message bon ça faisait toujours
plaisir
ouais
ok moi j'ai fini de manger mais
danger pour Maxime clairement danger
pour Maxime qui a l'air déçu à la caméra
pour se mettre une petite pub au passage
ça fait toujours plaisir
mais ouais quelle partie quelle partie
sympathique
comme une troupier c'était beau
ça a rendu très heureux comme une
trompière
était magnifique
ouais après moi ça me fait rire tous ces
messages
au final
on peut pas plaire à tout le monde
qu'est-ce que tu veux
est-ce que la nouvelle
alors non les nouvelles en fait je gagne
pas 100 000 dollars par an sur twitch
malheureusement pour moi même en brut
donc la nouvelle décision de twitch ne
m'impacte pas
du tout
assez d'argent même en brut terrible
même en brut sans compter les dépenses
c'est pour dire
je peux pas je sais pas sur quoi vous
répondez parce qu'il y a un gros délai
entre le Live et le moment où je vous
lis donc je peux pas savoir ce que
à quel moment quoi
mais après twitch va plus se payer les
pubs donc en fait
ça va compenser clairement
c'était sûr que ça arriverait trop tard
moi je pensais que ça arriverait plutôt
en réalité c'est que les très grosses
chaînes qui vont être impactées
genre le top
maximum
qui vont être impactés négativement pas
les autres
pour le moment
le délai c'est pour éviter la triche en
fait
c'est juste pour éviter la triche en
probablement 8e
ce serait magnifique si je jouais contre
Carlson
zeratoR
ouais mais parce qu'ils ont nettement
plus de sable que moi urban Spike donc
forcément ils sont plus impactés
si tu gagnes plus de 100000 dollars par
an sur les 7 et impactés
mais si tu gagnes moins de 100 000 par
an tu es pas impacté en fait
en brut attention donc en net ça
représente peut-être en plus tu enlèves
les fragments ou quoi ça représente
peut-être 20 ou 25000 euros par an
mais
ouais en fait si tu gagnes plus de
100.000 tu vas être impacté
tu vas pas être impacté
donc ouais après
c'est comme ça
pas impacté j'aurais jamais impacté par
ce truc là en fait
ça correspond à combien de sub
je pense que ça doit correspondre à 4000
sub
après dur à dire parce qu'il faut aussi
voir que tu as les sables et prime les
machins les beats mais je pense ça va
être à peu près autour de 4000
après ce sera appliqué évidemment à
partir du premier euro le 55 ans c'est
sûr
donc ouais
ça peut finir par pousser chez les gens
à plutôt stream sur Youtube non je pense
pas
mais après ça c'est du chiffre
d'affaires les 100 000 faut bien enfin
entre les frais machins ce que tu as
enfin à mon avis il faut bien enlever au
moins 75%
. qui sera jamais impacté
moins être au dessus de 4000 subs de
manière régulière
c'est difficile et quand bien même je
suis arrivé sur
5000 dollars par an 5000 dollars je
perdrai 30 %, je perdrai 1500 mais sur
ces 1500 j'aurais payé
65 % d'impôts donc tu as au pire du pire
si ça se passe très bien pour moi ça va
être impacté de 500 euros par an tu vois
enfin bon
donc ça peut pas
je veux pas être très impacté en fait
personnellement
non mais après les très gros streamer
ouais ils vont être très impactés c'est
sûr
comment ben ouais si tu commences à
gagner 300 ou 400 000 euros par an
de Seb ben tu seras impacté entre 100 et
enfin d'après ce que j'ai compris après
je suis pas rentré en détail entre 100
et 400000 tu seras payé tu perdras 29%,
tu vas ouais tu vas être vraiment
impacter
tout dépend combien tu gagnes en fait tu
gagnes beaucoup tu vas être impacté si
tu gagnes pas beaucoup tu vas pas être
impacté
pour le moment mais après ils ouvrent
peut-être la boîte de Pandore et on sera
impacté après
on peut pas savoir on verra
je vais me faire une micro pause je
reviens dans une minute
c'est bon je suis là
c'est quoi ton meilleur résultat en
Arena King à plusieurs victoires
plusieurs victoires en Arena King quand
même
ah on se présente un petit peu quand
on se présente quand même un petit peu
je sais pas combien j'en ai gagné mais
quelques-unes
à tout moment ça reclique
j'ai fait quoi et title tuesais je vais
faire 3e une fois ou deuxième troisième
peut-être deuxième ou troisième je sais
pas
Maxime qui a plus de Cam ok Maxime qui
est revenu Maxime qui va avoir les noirs
il est pas serein
OK
ça va être chaud la dernière
tu sais pas ce que va décider Maxime
bah en fait il passe à 55 ans à partir
de 100.000 dollars
les premiers cent mille dollars sont pas
impactés donc si tu gagnes moins de
100000 dollars tu es pas impacté et
comme je disais enfin j'aimerais éviter
pour la dernière fois mais c'est du brut
donc en net ça fait plutôt dans les
35000 euros si tu comptes pas les frais
que tu as on peut importe
si twitch te rapporte moins de 35000
euros par an et pas impacté si ça te
rapporte plus tu es impacté
en gros
ils font que de décaler leur truc
complexe
mais Maxime ouais il est pas trop sûr
c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait éviter
dans ce match
allez let's go let's go
let's go
enfin si tu habites en français
évidemment si tu habites dans un autre
pays c'est différent je parle en
législation française
let's go let's go let's go
pour tout le monde Saône ouais mais du
coup ils vont augmenter les pubs de
toute façon sur ça appartient en pub bon
allez let's go arrêtons de parler des
subs de twitch on en a plus rien à
[ __ ] allez let's go allez Maxime ouais
ça là il faut qu'il s'accroche on va
mettre les chiquer de l'autre côté pour
être en phase avec le design je suis
inquiet
je suis pas serein ok il a révisé Maxime
il a révisé parce que tout à l'heure on
avait vu qu'il fallait mieux mettre le
damassin sur échec allez c'est bien il
rend le coup du berger à la bergère
mais c'est bien ça ouais il veut
cavalier prend un froid pris à un prisin
et jouer sur le foie H6
faut qu'il se rappelle Maxime il faut
absolument qu'il se rappelle
il faut absolument qu'il se rappelle
alors qu'elle prend F3 il faut prendre
F3 bon alors les enjeux de la position
pour c'est trop compliqué en fait avec
il y a pas danger en fait c'est que
tactique on va être les échecs il y a
des fois ça s'explique des fois ça
s'explique pas là en gros on menace
fubéca de fou prend le 7 d'un côté
donc qui fait cavalier D3 prise D3
fougères 5 bon il connaît encore Maxime
je suis rassuré il menace tour prend B7
et fou prend le 7
et la ligne d'après ordi ça semblait
Tour Eiffel 8 tours B7 fous B5 enferme
le la Tour Eiffel vous prend B7 tour eb8
et il va récupérer en fullo
OK
ok Maxime qui s'est rappelé heureusement
et séviant là qui essaye de se rappeler
aussi
allez c'est bien Maxime qui a rendu
l'appareil quand même assez viandes qui
a sorti une belle prépa dans la partie
précédente il s'est rappelé de tout
jusqu'au bout Samuel
enfin Sam ou Samuel j'ai l'impression
que c'est Samuel perso son prénom mais
peu importe
donc là ouais en gros il va il peut
prendre deux punch mais d'un autre côté
Maxime va récupérer la tourelle et si
sur fou B5 on voit du cavalier des doses
il va y avoir poussé trois
et ça va prendre en F1
OK
donc la ligne ça semble ça on va on va
regarder la ligne tour reprend B7 faut
B5 vous prend le 7
dames.fr s'activent
on récupère à deux et c'est juste une
nul en fait
ok ça passe
c'est connu par Maxime allez c'est cool
je vous prends le sept ça rentre c'est
c'est la ligne alors après est-ce que
c'est tout Abi tour à 8 est-ce que c'est
tout eb8 ça j'en sais rien mais ça passe
alors dit propose de commencer parfois
si éventuellement bon il y a plusieurs
options mais l'important à retenir
là-dedans c'est que Maxime s'est rappelé
loin de la théorie là on est encore dans
la prépa on est au 20e coup Maxime se
met peut-être à réfléchir mais il sait
que c'est égal
donc on est on est rassuré
et donc c'est quoi la règle en cas de
départage est-ce que il y a un Samir
Robin dans dans le ce que je crois
qu'ils ont mis un
Armageddon j'ai regardé d'autres matchs
et je crois que derrière c'est un
Armageddon c'est pas le mort subite et
l'Armageddon me fait suer d'avance
voilà ça peut faire turbo dro
l'armée d'avance bon là maxime a réussi
à se rappeler et à réussir à fermer la
porte
je sais pas s'il vaut mieux qu'on soit
au blanc au noir je sais pas si on s'est
mis en Robin un violon qui a une donnée
la règle exacte
mais moritest oui enfin mémoritesse
réussie
est-ce qu'il va faire tour à 8 et drôle
est-ce qu'il va faire tourner deux non
c'est tout à 8 et 8 et drôle OK
all good ça va vers nul ouais ça c'est
sûr c'est nul
après ça peut déconner mais ça c'est sûr
c'est nul
ça va faire 5 contre 3 pions sur la même
aile il va faire fouet 8 on reprend F8
c'est la variante que j'ai montrée juste
avant théorie
c'est la théorie jusque là en fait donc
il faut prendre fui trois points
qu'elle soit après sable je voudrais
qu'il soit rappelé à proprement parler
de la théorie jusqu'au bout mais juste
il a retrouvé à la main quoi alors
attendez il y a une question quand même
vous prend fui trois points légers
H6 cavalier.f7 tu reprends le 4 ok et
les tourterelles s'activent et ça peut
carrément être dangereux pour les blancs
ici
ok c'est en chair oh [ __ ] c'est en
chair sermaidon enchères oh le malaise
termine par une égalité une seule partie
rapide
et doivent gagner avec un système
d'enchères pour déterminer qui a les
noirs
alors Maxime il a quoi comme strat
il joue plus vite que ses viandes
va dire
10 minutes je pense
Maxime va dire 10 minutes
ouais c'est en chair c'est enchères
caché comme pour la pour la Ligue 1 au
foot
je pense que Maxime va dire 10 minutes
c'est le meilleur système pour
pour l'armée dans le système d'enchères
c'est le plus juste ça met les deux
joueurs sur un pied d'égalité avant la
partie
très cool comme système les enchères
parce que l'Armageddon les Noirs gagnent
en cas de nul
donc moins tas de temps mieux c'est je
pense que Maxime ouais va dire 10
minutes ça doit lui suffire si c'est
bien on dit 9 il va lui mettre tellement
le bouillon à la pendule
que ça va suer
mais c'est bien on va pas dire neuf
allons mis 6 minutes 6 minutes c'est
dangereux quand même
la Ligue 1 quand ils achètent les droits
on peu importe je suis pareil avec le
chat cachés
je pense que Maxime va dire 10 minutes
et il aura les noirs
peut-être qu'il va même se sentir de
dire moi je sais pas toujours un peu
dangereux
le problème c'est que tu vas en perdre
si tu fais 5 tu auras 8
ton pion je vais le bouffer en a deux et
qualité c'est juste nul ce genre de truc
on va voir comment mais le match est
plus serré qu'on ne lui espère
sa deuxième partie coûte cher à Maxime
quand même où il a été clairement en
dessous
il s'est il s'est réellement
trop relâché attention ça ça peut être
risqué
ça ça peut être dangereux
non en fait il échange tout il va perdre
à deux c'est mieux complètement nul ça
Maxime va récupérer des 5 à 2 c'est
complètement nul
là il y a même pas
je sais pas à quoi réfléchissez en fait
c'est dur à savoir
dépend des rajouts des machins c'est
compliqué
deuxième partie ça m'a bien joué ouais
ouais mais bon Maxime devait serrer à la
vis
4 pions c'est beaucoup ouais mais là ça
en fait trois puis ça va bientôt en
faire deux
et ça c'est nul très facile
ça à ce niveau là c'est nul sans forcer
je savais même pas de la gagner avec les
Blancs
en fait
elle est trop forte mais des échecs de
loin est trop forte
une nouvelle fois c'est pas une nul
difficile normalement
ouais je pense que c'est bien on va même
pas tenter de la gagner
on laisse la tour loin loin du cavalier
sur la colonne à pour pas qu'il y ait de
fourchette
et on attend
le format du tournoi assez cool ils ont
réussi à faire un truc court et sympa là
on est à 2h20 de match si ça fait nul on
sera à 2h30 2h40 et on a l'armée Guédon
donc c'est des matchs qui durent
au maximum trois heures trois heures
trente si ils sont très serrés moi je
trouve qu'on est sur un format très
sympa
plus facile au noir comme on a la tour
non ce serait plutôt les blancs qui fait
un qui presseraient non mais ça c'est
nul juste
Maxime va être précis et j'ai 5 pour pas
perdre la moindre colonne
il préfère être bien concentré on va
vivre un Armageddon de folie
ça va être sympa alors ma guidon non
joli format là pour la peine autant de
chaisescom n'a pu nous habituer par le
passé avec des formats un peu bizarre et
un peu relou à suivre
autant là il faut dire que c'est pas le
cas
c'est un format agréable
c'est un format relativement agréable à
suivre
on va réussir à faire les deux pions
passés liés mais c'est juste nul après
il va se faire
ah non tu essayes quand même un peu avec
les Blancs
il a raison
ce match est d'aller toujours être serré
c'est dommage maxime a été tellement
dominé la première game
il avait tellement dominé la première
c'est dommage
on va attendre un là il y a pas de on va
se garder notre énergie il y a pas
vraiment de suspense
on va essayer de faire chier avec ces
deux pions quand même parce qu'en même
s'il perd les pions en fait roi cavaler
contre un tour c'est nul
pas très dur
ouais il va essayer de jouer ça et bon
c'est nul vous allez voir
Maxime qui joue quand même nettement
plus vite que c'est bien
ça partie se terminer
complexe
ça clique fort
OK
un vélo seul à faire du tournoi ouais
ouais les autres joueurs français n'ont
pas
n'ont pas réussi la qualif
malheureusement
là ça va répéter ouais comme je vous
disais hein qui ont aucun intérêt je
vous mets pas j'aime pas vous mettre de
suspense quand il y en a pas
donc ouais on va je sais pas quand on va
être l'armage et non c'est pas qu'elle
sera la couleur on va pas avoir accès
au système d'enchères
mais j'espère que Maxime
va avoir les Noirs quand même il a fait
nulle facilement
normalement les Noirs c'est vraiment
la couleur de prédilection là pour
Maxime
c'est là qu'il faut faire les le Punto
on va voir comme je disais moi je parie
sur Maxime 10 minutes au noir
à l'Arena King était hyper dur ce soir
heureusement que je suis pas tombé
dessus avec les 2800 ça aurait été
insupportable c'était hyper fort
sur Oui il joue pas juste
qui m'a fait chier la semaine dernière
avec ses 27 50 en fait il est 28 70 là
j'avais senti que ça je mets fort
e
étant ça on peut pas te dire en fait
je sais pas à quel point il y a des
stats
[Musique]
les califes pas assez
Maxime
5 minutes ça peut passer ouais
il pourrait jouer avec 5 minutes et
passer ouais
on va pas savoir là pour pour
l'Armageddon mais ça va bientôt
commencer ça va être cool
Maxime qui a sorti un nouveau blog je
vois
on connaît pas les couleurs non c'est un
système d'enchères mais je pense qu'on
va les connaître au moment où ça démarre
c'était 10 vs 7 qui étaient avantages
des blancs en or ouais ouais mais après
c'est un peu revenu
moi je pense Maxime doit ouais peut-être
même il doit dire neuf ou huit ans
9 9 contre 15 9 ou 8 je sais pas
je vois tellement passer viens prendre
moins de 10 minutes
peut-être lâcher une grosse enchère peut
avoir les dents ouais mais bon on l'a vu
en difficulté autant dans toutes les
parties
les deux joueurs ont gagné une partie au
blanc je sais pas
j'ai pas complexe on va voir on attend
en train de regarder vite fait ce qui se
passait sur Twitter
en attendant la suite j'ai oublié de
mettre la petite pub
on a déjà tout dit la partie d'avant
elle fait le taf est difficile avec ce
délai de réagir avec le chat donc on est
un peu un peu bloqué
celui qui annonce le moins de temps
prend les Noirs en fait
celui qui prend le moins de temps elle
est noire
c'est aussi simple que ça
désolé de pas pouvoir exactement réagir
comme je le souhaiterais
au chat c'est juste que ouais
c'est juste qu'on est bloqué on attend
que la partie commence là je peux pas je
peux pas avoir les infos je regarde mais
je trouve pas
les Noirs gagne s'y font nuls toujours
les mêmes règles
je sais pas s'il y a un endroit où il y
a le
les enchères
non je vois pas
c'est fixé ça dépend de celui qui ont
les Noirs les Blancs je crois qu'ils ont
15 minutes dans tous les cas je crois
Maxime 11 minutes ok je pensais qu'il
prendrait 10 mais il a dû comprendre que
c'est bien on prendrait pas moins
j'arrive je reprends un tout petit truc
à manger et je vais être en pleine forme
pour l'Armageddon
ouais c'est 11 minutes il a clairement
il aurait pu prendre lui tout neuf mais
il a dû sentir que c'est bien prendre
beaucoup donc c'est bien joué de la part
de Maxime on ça doit aller
en réalité la grosse question que
j'étais en train de me poser c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est bien on va jouer
en fait
en fait c'est ça la grosse question à se
poser comment est-ce que c'est Vian il
joue parce que
la grille une femme Maxime il l'a fermé
il doit retourner dessus et tenter une
petite ligne et espérer que Maxime se
trompe je pense
après Maxime il peut aussi décider
d'aller sur un Gambie d'un accepté
il peut aussi il peut aussi décaler sur
un gambidam accepté
donc là ça se voit que les deux joueurs
trichent pas
là pour la peine ça se voit quand même
que les deux joueurs trichent pas
sur les parties
pour et tu me diras tu es jamais sur à
100%
vu l'époque dans laquelle on vit au
tempo
c'est bien il avait demandé 12,5 et
Maxime m'a demandé 11
ils ont fait une enchère cachée en fait
donc tu tapes ton enchère le tape son
enchère et
et celui qui a mis le moins aller noir
donc Maxime aura les pièces noires dans
cette Armageddon
allez il faut il faut jouer solide bien
sortir de l'ouverture et ça devrait le
faire en sifflotant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans les autres matchs d'ailleurs
on en a pas reparlé parce qu'on était
vraiment concentré sur Maxime
il semble que Carole moi je le vois en
tout petit truc je vais me l'agrandir ça
permettra à ceux qui ont un petit écran
comme moi de voir
sans que karwana sont en train de gagner
que André King badcam si ouais pas de
surprise
allez
on attend que les deux hommes ça se
talent
ou alors avec ces viandes tu pars sur 4
et tu vas dans la nage d'or
mais bon
ça peut être une autre solution je pense
pour ces viandes à deux idées
soit tu vas plein faire sur la greenfel
des tu as une deuxième idée dans
l'ouverture
soit tu tapes sur la nage d'or
ouais ça dépend de ce que tu as en stock
mais aller sur la nage d'or fait pas si
du haut pour lui
et pour Maxime est-ce que tu décales sur
un gambida m'a accepté
dans ce côté tu as pas vu sa prépa tu as
égaliser dans la deuxième je pense
Maxime tu restes sur grunefeld
grunfelnage d'or
tu bouges pas en fait
tu penses que tu es Maxime ouais tu
restes solide sur ta gueule une fête tu
t'emmerde pas de toute façon si feux 4
tu vas sur ton mail
tu vas pas t'emmerder à faire une
Française trop dangereux
j'imagine
ça va être intéressant et cavalier F3
évidemment tu crains jamais trop même si
ça peut être une option parfois cavalier
F3 quand tu sais plus trop quoi faire
non je suis impatient que ça démarre
petite pub quand même pour être bien sûr
sinon on n'est pas bien sûr
[Musique]
en tout cas
que les autres matchs se terminent
Maxime qui a le temps d'aller réviser
ses biens ça
il faut se qualifier si je Maxime sort
aussitôt cette compétition aura déjà
plus de joueurs français
après seulement deux tours
15 minutes pour les blancs 11 minutes
pour les Noirs les noirs peuvent faire
nul pour se qualifier ça c'est assez
simple équation
désolé c'est hyper frustrant d'être
autant en décalage avec le chat
et la France ouais
il a sûrement un autre ordi Maxime
c'est qui les autres Français en liste
bah il y en a plus
à la base qualifié aucun par Maxime
maxime est le seul à avoir réussi à être
dans le grand tableau
après il était qualifié d'office c'était
pas très dur
on attend
sûrement d'autres parties qui sont
encore en cours j'ai pas envie de rater
il y aurait sûrement une game en fait
celle-là
ah mais André King qui va se faire
égaliser
Sandrine avec les noirs
du truc c'est pour ça que je veux pas
trop bouger
les mecs qui sont éliminés qui se barent
il y a les losers qui partent donc là
Sandrine avec les Noirs mais comme je
vous dis moi je veux vraiment pas rater
le
je vais pas me rater parce que
l'Armageddon c'est un peu le truc
intéressant
ok les mecs se barre en fait
moi je veux pas me je veux pas me rater
donc en fait les noirs doivent faire nul
là pour se qualifier
et c'est peut-être nul ce truc
intuitivement j'aurais fait fouder deux
mais bon
là il a perdu un tempo
du coup Laura rime en dessin et c'est
terminé
il va pouvoir bouffer bouffer
je pensais faire foudre
je pense à relativement vite partir
derrière et donc camski qui égalise qui
envoie un Armageddon aussi
donc on attend le retour de séviant
je sais pas ça parle
en fait le truc c'est que les deux
matchs sont gérés tous les matchs sont
gérés par la même production les matchs
sont tous en même temps
et comme il y a beaucoup de matchs en
fait c'est ça qui crée un peu la ce
délai
maintenant les prochaines je sais pas
c'est 20h55 ou 21h
très franchement c'est difficile à gérer
pour
d'avoir des infos pour le casque
international
en fait ça dépendait de la fin des
autres parties donc là j'imagine que ça
va être 21h
Maxime qui se concentre
ça va être un enfer en fait
c'est un enfer en fait
allez faut que Max fasse le taf
faut absolument que Max fasse le taf ici
ça va jouer sur une seule partie
[Musique]
dans ce on va voir
il a perdu contre gérer
il a fait nulle va aller renulatina et
la battu Espinosa
qui perd 6 points
dur pour son équipe
je vais contre un Péruvien quoi péruvien
c'est
il était gagnant ou pas
péruvien sont toujours giga dangereux
il faut qu'on soit fou l'énergie là pour
Star McDon
alors le Péruvien qui a bien défendu
caméra qui suit
ouais mais c'est chiant en fait c'est
les gars ils partent et rendent du truc
zoom donc ça décale tout le temps
c'est insupportable
mais vous inquiétez pas je suis sur le
coup j'ai bien cadré le truc donc ça va
marcher au moment précis
je suis sûr que ça à 21h
le début de la game
insupportable en fait le truc de réglage
caméra
ouais non c'est
en fait ils arrêtent pas de décaler le
truc quoi
je sais pas comment c'est possible
mais
ouais les cames il faudrait qu'il trouve
une autre manière en fait
ce que je peux pas savoir s'il y a une
canne qui va se rajouter ou pas quoi
c'est compliqué quoi
OK
j'essaie de faire les choses pour que
vous ayez
à la meilleure expérience visuelle
possible
non mais bon comme on attend et qu'on a
rien à faire autant les cadrer
mais juste c'est pas évident parce que
les cames elles tournent
mais ok c'est pas aussi plaisir de voir
la préparation des joueurs Maxime
concentré à les let's go le requin allez
requinade
il a l'air stressé c'est bien quand même
la morsure de requin peut faire mal
allez mon Maxou let's go
allez let's go let's go let's go let's
go
ça devrait commencer dans une minute
maintenant
ouais ça y est ça va partir ça va partir
avec un requin avec les pièces noires
qui va faire mal il nage en haute mer là
pour pour cette Armageddon et on sait
que plus l'eau est profonde plus il fait
des belles morsures sur les côtés il
avait il avait fait mal un certain
saumon aux championnats du monde de
Blitz
non mais attends ils sont encore en
train de ça retarde le match à cause à
cause du broadcast américain allez let's
go là on arrête là allez on arrête la
pub là ils sont pris quoi ils ont cru
que c'était le super ball les frérots
c'est pas le super beau ici c'est pas la
capitale c'est Marseille bébé
ça parle
nous ce qu'on veut c'est voir des game
maintenant il y en a marre la
discutailler d'attendre André kidn
machin va falloir attendre c'est qui qui
commente va falloir attendre que S soit
les pisser qui soit revenu des chiottes
moi je dis en a marre bon c'est une
Gotham non bah oui mais bon c'est pour
ça qu'il y a du retard
on comprend on comprend pourquoi on doit
attendre allez let's go là on lance
allez c'est parti Maxime avec les Noirs
qu'est-ce qui va nous faire c'est quoi
trop ah c'est bien pourquoi il y a 15
minutes ok il y a 11 minutes pour Maxime
ça part c'est quoi trop sa réfléchit
Maxime qui doit se demander sur cavalier
M6 qu'est-ce qu'il veut et Maxime qui
fait 5 allez joli décalage de Maxime qui
qui sait que Sam séviant à une idée
derrière la tête et il joue ses 6 alors
il y a la variante avec des 4 cartes qui
peut éventuellement ressembler à de la
française bizarre de loin il y a
cavalier F3 E4 cavalier D4 qui est un
genre dalapine avec un temps de moins
donc là on est vraiment dans une à
lapine à couleur inversée où il y aurait
eu le G6 en plus
dame prend E3 dame 5 ouais ça c'est une
grosse variante là actuellement il y a
eu quelques parties là dessus
et Maxime qui a réussi à décaler dans
l'ouverture c'est bon il est il a réussi
à éviter la prépa et ce qui connaît bien
la position
j'imagine que oui je pense que fearuja
peut avoir ça dans son répertoire et on
sait que Maxime fait des Blitz
d'entraînement avec Ali Rosa
et là voilà très bonne nouvelle c'est
que ça me sévit on commence déjà à
prendre dans son temps alors si vous de
vous demander pourquoi maxime n'a plus
de 10 minutes 45 c'est très simple au
début de la partie Sam séviant avec 15
minutes maxime a dit moi avec 11 minutes
si j'ai les Noirs je peux faire nul et
me qualifier ça me sévit avait proposé
12 minutes 30 maxime a remporté
l'enchère et donc Maxime un retard
autant handicap mais il a l'avantage que
nul lui permet de gagner la partie après
l'actuellement on a une position assez
tendue on voit que la structure est
complètement asymétrique ici avec ce
pion E4 qui avançait sur l'échiquier
donc évidemment on est content d'avoir
pris de l'espace côté noir mais on voit
que les blancs sont prêts à rebondir il
y a déjà deux pièces qui tapent sur le
pion il y a ce cavalier qui peut revenir
en haut trois il y a le pion des trois
qui peut le débouchaîner mais derrière
il y aura encore le petit muret B7 C6
position compliquée ici un coup comme
cavalier A6 et thématique pour revenir
vers ces cinq
moi j'ai envie de dire ouais pour le
moment où il a fait faux sept meilleur
Sky ici ce qui a été 5 et aussi possible
j'ai envie de dire après rock peut-être
Maxime rock rapidement et on verra après
attention aussi au plan cavaliers 3
dames C2 et donc là peut-être cavalier à
6 peut être pas mal d'âme C2 cavalier
c'est 5 mais B4 il faut regarder ces
choses là on peut aussi passer par des 7
mais cavaliers à 6 dames C2 il y a aussi
cavalier B4 dam B1 il y a beaucoup
d'options il faut juste être méfiant de
pas aller se faire encaisser le Punto
parce que dams et de cavalier prend en
quatre c'est deux coups et ça gagne le
pion donc cavalier à 6 dames C2 il
faudra il faut y réfléchir est-ce que
cavalier c'est 5 B 4
c'est un problème ou pas la question est
posée moi je pose des questions je vais
pas y répondre après une fois que le
pion est en B4 c'est cloué mais le temps
de côté quand il fait damser de fou B2
ça ça met un vis-à-vis dans la dame
position difficile 930 9 30 pour Maxime
on n'a pas les pendules du bon côté il
faut qu'on se mette côté blanc désolé
on est on est à l'envers on est à
l'envers c'est trop l'habitude de mettre
de côté Maxime
ça ça inverse le truc mais bon vous avez
bien compris que Maxime a les noirs de
toute façon vu que c'est écrit devant sa
caméra
et donc s'inverse et on se fait
tellement plaisir d'être côté Maxime
donc il y a 1000 cavaliers à 6
il veut cavalier C5 Maxime
éventuellement
il veut faire cavalier ses 5 Maxime
c'est quoi c'est dames c'est deux
cavalier BK
F5 touche le fou pour rentrer en C2 fou
B1 full 6
c'est quoi les valves de cette position
honnêtement on serait pas on serait pas
super heureux de l'avoir
il a fait à trois
et rock
ok BK
alors
l'idée de séance c'est quoi c'est fou B2
dame C2 et taper 4
donc pour 8 il va faire fou B2
fois8 Maxime qui a réussi à tenir le
pion mais attention on a ce cavalier en
6 qui est
qui est loin du jeu on a fion E4 qui est
fragile on a du mal à toucher le
cavalier genre pour illustrer disons que
les Blancs joue damso2 on va mettre le
fond F8 on a du mal à toucher le
cavalier pour mettre le pion F5 du coup
Maxime va probablement partir pour un
plan de type cavalier C7 cavalier D5
pour replacer ce cavalier et essayer de
prendre le cavalier C3 peut-être pour
abaisser la pression sur le pion E4
donc on va voir est-ce qu'il va mettre
la dame en C2
fouet 8
et il peut peut-être tenter de jouer
avec du cavalier A4 pour essayer de
toucher la case C5
il y a beaucoup de pièces sur les
chiquer Maxime qui est revenu au temps
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
onze minutes 20 contre 903
Maxime qui est bien autant quand même il
revient fort et pour le moment c'est
viande trouve pas vraiment la clé dans
cette position d'AMS et de fouet fuite
ça c'est sûr vous décises alors très
étonnant pour moi un coup comme fou des
6 parce qu'on dit souvent que le fouet
est bien placé en F8 proche du roi il
défend le roi et il gêne pas sur les
colonnes et en venant des 6 en plus là
il tape sur la case G3 mais à mon avis
ce donc qui sur du solide mais à mon
avis ça peut être expliqué
par le fait qu'il veut jouer fou E5
Maxime et venir jouer cahier des cinq
fouets 5 et vraiment liquider le
matériel s'il y arrive évidemment c'est
fort
là pour avoir votre information
l'ordinateur propose comme seule manière
de jouer pour l'avantage un truc très
difficile des trois pions prend qui sera
à mon avis pas joué parce que ça pourrit
la structure mais ok on peut comprendre
niveau jeu pour du cavalier C4 jouer sur
le fouet etc mais ça paraît trop
difficile
donc qu'est-ce que va jouer Sam c'est
viande
quelles sont ses options il y a quand
même cavalière à 4 en option parce que
sur B6 Adam français 6 ah il y aurait
peut-être fou des sept dames et de bon
avoir mes cavaliers A4 est une option
c'est sûr ça se regarde
F3 en est une autre alors il veut pion
prend
et il veut prendre à mon avis de la tour
ouais alors ces positions là il y a un
enjeu
incroyable c'est est-ce que les Blancs
réussissent à faire au 4 des 4 en gros
si c'est viande et les pions E4 et des 4
il est mieux en fait ça à faire un
rouleau compresseur à terme il va enfin
il va réussir à mettre la marche avant
il va faire mal par contre s'il y arrive
pas ça va aller ce qui me déplaît ici
dans la position de Maxime c'est qu'il y
a une menace hyper forte pour les blancs
c'est cavaliers F5 D4 E4 E5 en fait si
sévi on réussit enchaîner ces trois
coups sévion est mieux et ce four en E5
de Maxime me déplaît fortement parce
qu'il est venu Maxime en fait il est
bien placé son fou mais il est dans le
trafic c'est à dire que regarder si les
blancs réussissent à faire cavalier F5
D4 je touche le fou le four parent des 6
E4 donc imaginez les deux pions E4 D4 je
menacerai déjà E5 fourchettes j'espère
que vous l'avez dans le chat c'est une
menace forte dans la position on peut
pas se permettre de jouer j'ai ici c'est
trop dégueulasse la
les Blancs ont déjà mis lors de Tours
dessus et le fou B2 il tape sur F6 donc
ça c'est un énorme problème le long de
la colonel
et la menace de la position elle est
simple cavalier D5 à pas l'air d'être
une option à cause de cavalier prend et
j'imagine qu'il y a un problème un jour
sur le pion F7 qui paraît assez faible
je dirais pour le moment que l'ouverture
est ratée côté Maxime Le Fou des 6 x 5 a
été réfuté par le plan de séviants
d'ouvrir la colonne F et d'aller taper
sur F5 maxime est en danger dans ce
16ème de finale du Global cheescom
champion'sheep 2022 avec je le rappelle
plus d'un million de dollars de prix
200000 dollars au vainqueur du tournoi
donc une coquette somme à gagner et pour
le moment c'est séviant qui dans
l'ouverture à la surprise générale on
sentait que Maxime était pas mal sorti
et là un petit coup à côté le fou des 6
et la position de Maxime est
immédiatement compliqué on nous propose
dans le chat un coup comme foodé 4
qui peut être intéressant mais foudé 4
j'ai peur juste de roicher décalage puis
cavaliers F5 quand même puis 3 puis des
quatre puis quatre puis cinq ça avance
fort Maxime en danger ici Maxime qui
prend son temps au bon moment j'ai envie
de dire mais peut-être un coup trop tard
c'est peut-être le fou des 6 qui est
parti trop vite
et là toutes les pièces sont mal
organisées regardez le cavalier c'est 7
qui a pas vraiment le rebonder 5 il y a
pas de rebond aussi le Foussais 8 qui
est bloqué la tour à 8 qui joue pas des
7 ça paraît mou cavalier F5 rentre forts
ça me séviant qui est en train de
prendre la confiance regardez ça se voit
c'est visuel là il bouge vite les vieux
les yeux il a trois minutes d'avance il
réussit à augmenter la pression sur
Maxime à Maxime qui est dans le dur
Maxime dans le très très dur allez il
faut mettre deux trois barres bols là
les amis nous faut peut-être un mur de
barbelés dans ce chat pour réussir ah à
serrer la vis ça match à élimination
directe ainsi Maxime percette parti il
sort dès le deuxième tour on se croirait
quasiment à Roland-Garros seul joueur
sorti des califes Maxime tête de série
du tournoi et pourtant et pourtant il
semble déjà en danger des son premier
match un petit peu un petit peu
difficile plus que 5 minutes 50 les
secondes qui s'égraine on sait que
Maxime a une grosse point de vitesse
mais quand même c'est
ça traduit ça traduit une difficulté
dans la position on a compris le l'enjeu
et on comprend le problème cavalier F5
des 4 4 qui peut partir à une vitesse
grand V le fou qui va être moche tout va
être moche
il est en train de réfléchir si un G6
passe à mon avis pour essayer
d'interdire cavalier F5 mais ça doit
être peine perdu
en C5 le cavalier F6 qui semble battre
de l'aile
et les secondes sont longues à un côté
un supporter français on est déjà plus
de 3 minutes de réflexion et dame 7 et
oui Maxime qui décide de cavalier F5 à
voir que fou prend F5 donc Maxime qui
accepte d'être moins bien mais qui veut
rendre la tâche longue et pénible à
samsevian s'il veut remporter la partie
alors ici il y a une autre option il y a
un cavalier F5 qui donne envie mais
aussi cavalier C4 pour essayer Kota
américain d'aller s'emparer plutôt du
foodcase noir pour taper hein fort et
dur avec le fou B2 ah ouais le fou B2
qui peut rentrer fort dur il est très
pénétrant là sur sur la case G7 avec en
plus les deux tours il y a pénétration
sur la colonne F pour pour samsevian et
sur la diagonale à un G7 donc là il y a
une double pénétration dans la dans la
position et ça fait mal un pour le
moment côté Maxime cavalier C4 voilà ça
peut ça peut aller prendre le fouet 5
et taper fort
cavaler ces quatre peut-être Maxime veut
fouger 4 mais il y aura tout trois foot
et quatre allez c'est ça l'idée de
Maxime il veut cavaler ses quatre fous
G4 il y a pas de tour E3 à cause de
foodé 4 mais il y a peut-être cavalier
prend le 5 intermédiaires et on n'a pas
de fous prends F3 à cause de cavalier
prend ouais ça peut ça peut être dur ça
peut être difficile ça peut être
difficile
cavalier c'est quoi trop on peut pas
sauver ce fou et sur foodé 4 échec
direct E3 fouger 4 ne passe pas il y a
encore puis on prend des quatre et on
reprend F3 au cavalier C4 a l'air
vraiment fort alors l'ordi donne
cavalier C4 cavaliers F5 comme deux
coups équivalents mais d'un point de vue
pratique je peux vous dire que cavalier
C4 fait mal parce qu'une fois que ce
fouet 5 il a disparu aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
le fou B2 qui va taper fort et dur
celui-là il est il est en ligne droite
il est en ligne droite la diagonale elle
est bien levée là
c'est pas c'est pas du demi tapage sur
sur la diagonale et il fait cavalier F5
on souffle un peu on souffle un peu côté
français c'est avantage c'est avantage
blanc oui mais à mon avis on souffle
quand même parce que le roi est quand
même moins faible alors il va vouloir
jouer pour B5 il va vouloir nous taper
de l'autre côté mais bon c'est pas le
roi qui a attaqué c'est une partie un
peu plus au long cours Maxime va avoir
le temps de revenir dedans
il va avoir le temps de revenir dans
cette partie fout des quatre échecs ça
semble pas être un coup il y a E3
peut-être Dame des 7 un petit décalage
de la dame attention quand même oh ça
peut tellement rentrer de partout
je sais pas je commence à avoir des
cavaliers 4 il y a peut-être des tours
F7 qui marche dans certaines positions
Maxime qui a toujours 3 minutes de
retard qui arrive pas à se refaire
ah ouais c'est dur
là c'est dur Dame des 7 jouets
alors on est rassuré côté Val je vous
fais un tout petit point il y a qu'un
coup qui donne l'avantage pour les
blancs c'est un coup très logique mais
CE3 mais là ça peut tanker côté ça parce
que cavalier 4 visuellement on a envie
de le regarder on n'arrive pas trop à le
faire marcher vous prend B2 dames prends
B2 ca va les prendre
F7 c'est une petite variante à
l'emporte-pièce sûrement pas la main
mais passe pas donc il a le 3 il va
avoir le D4 il va avoir le 4 c'est le
scénario dont je vous parlais oh la
marche avant émise là
le plan main est en train de prendre
forme là pour Sam je vous en ai parlé il
y a une dizaine de coups je vous ai dit
le plan des blancs ici c'est E4 D4 c'est
mettre les pions et avancer ce faire
avancer ce rouleau compresseur
et Maxime qui va tenter le blocus sur
casse blanche allez Maxime il faut
l'arrêter ce rouleau fous des 6
peut-être mettre le foin et fuite ok des
4 jouets fous des 6 ça va être joué je
vous ai dit ça c'est le plan principal
equattro maintenant qui va partir
et il va falloir sur 5 essayer de faire
un gros blocus sur la case
sur la case des 5 alors juste pour
revenir on pouvait pas faire de fou
français 3 auparavant d'armes français 3
dame on va se prendre cette batterie qui
clôture la game hein c'est je reviens
très rapidement là-dessus c'est une
question qui revenait donc il a réussi à
faire le D4 à faire le 4 et l'objectif
dont je vous parlais ici après F3 E3 F3
dames.f3 objectif stratégique à long
terme mettre les pions des quatre et E4
objectif qui a été réalisé par samsevian
qui prend le contrôle du centre et qui
menace maintenant E5 cavalu aussi pour
Maxime allez ça commence les problèmes
pour Sam 5 cavaliers prend des quatre
allez le marlou est de sortie le marlou
est de sortie cavalieux de ça défend
pour le moment ouais c'est bien défendu
ce centre assez dur là le centre qui est
complètement blindé par les pièces
mineures fossette alors là est-ce qu'il
y a pas e5ae 5 Caval et 5 on souffle tu
reprends F7 cavalue 3
on est zen on est encore là ça passe
encore pour le moment côté Maxime mais
on va on va pouvoir mettre un barbelant
F8 défendre le pion F7 coûte que coûte
et espérer que les Blancs avancent un
moment et créer le blocus
55 38 j'ai l'impression qu'il y a pas de
rajout de temps
il faut que Maxime défendent il faut
qu'il en mette des barbelés là allez si
ça si si on rentre dans la minute après
dans les deux minutes là chacun
Maxime pourra faire parler sa pointe de
vitesse mais il va falloir y arriver il
va falloir survivre mais là c'est bien
ce que fait Maxime il a réussi à
garder une position difficile
parce que la poussée E5 semble pas
marcher à cause qu'il y a des seins qui
fait damséen ou malin il veut 5 et 5
tours
Maxime qui fait la tour en fuite ces
choses faites et maintenant attention
peut-être un coup comme dessin un peu
partir ça va lui ouvrir le fou F2 ça
peut être fort allez faut que ça me
sévion ressente le souffle de Maxime là
derrière sa nuque il sait que Maxime
c'est un des joueurs les plus marlou les
plus malins ceux que celui de ceux qui
arnaque le mieux dans le circuit
il faut que ça me sévi on ressente un
petit peu cette pression du requin aux
dents
j'ai envie de dire aiguiser
et la tour qui est venu en E8 pour le
moment elle est poussée de pions sont
pas à son pas si folichonne
H6 et ce qu'il y a [ __ ] F6 puis on
prend G5 dames rangées 5 fous prends F6
tours F6 les caméras qui ont été
décalées on va essayer de les retrouver
rapidement quand même c'est trop
important de réussir à avoir les joueurs
ici je peux pas ne pas ne pas voir la
bouille de Maxime allez c'est récupéré
la régie qui fait le travail allez la
tour peut-être en G5 h6 il y a pas de il
y a pas de chaos il y a pas de chaos
pour le moment heureusement
heureusement parce qu'on est vraiment
pas loin de la correction oh il y a
peut-être ça oh le malaise
all malaise ça passe pas ça passe pas
et leur dit d'un tourgé 5 quand même sur
H6 lors dire quelque chose
tu reprends G7 trois projets 7 et D6
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible
dame prend des 6 c'est cavaliers des
quatre ça va pas être trouvé ça par Sam
ça c'est trop dur ça c'est trop dur
Maxime qui va faire H6
allez ça a l'air de tenir pour le moment
ça a l'air de tenir pour Maxime
on va garder les calmes quand même pour
avoir les joueurs mais ça a l'air
H6
si la tour reprend G7 c'est terminé mais
ça me paraît introuvable ton projet
c'est trois points G7 D6 et cavaliers
des 4 c'est très dur ah s'il a des si
c'est terminé ça me sévitant qu'il y a
une balle de match ici ouais ici il fait
tout reponger ces trois projets cette D6
ça tire la dame prend des six et
cavaliers des 4 s'en est fini de
désespoir de Maxime après ces cavaliers
F5 échecs dame prend H6 ça rentre comme
papa dans maman oh c'est le coup de la
partie sinon c'est ton GF5 et l'ordi
donne égal oh c'est maintenant les amis
oh là qu'est-ce que c'est beau ton
projet ces trois projets 7 et D6 ça a
été complètement raté par Maxime c'est
extrêmement dur il a il lent il l'a ça
me séviant oh c'est terrible Maxime qui
va disparaître du tableau éliminer
quasiment maintenant du Global cheesecom
Championship ah ça sentait il y avait du
temps prend G7 dans l'air et ça a été
trouvé par samsevian et Maxime qui va
prendre la porte des ce deuxième tour
ouais c'est la correctionnelle là pour
le champion du monde de Blitz
c'est terrible ce que ce que Samuel
Sevian vient de viendrait réussir à
faire la position était difficile et
réussie à à faire sauter les cases
noires
Maxime qui aura peut-être fait un choix
discutable dans l'ouverture mais
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
de la part de Samse Évian bon c'est
trouvable à arrêter dans le chat de
raconter de la merde c'est trouvable des
escape parce que tu regardes que ça mais
ça me séviant qui trouve une magnifique
combinaison et c'est gagné ça me séviant
qui a sué mais qui est qualifié Maxime
qui se déconnecte immédiatement et donc
il n'y a plus de joueurs français dans
ce global cheesecom Championship Maxime
qui pourra s'en vouloir non pas d'avoir
perdu cet Armageddon puisque finalement
ça me sévient à araignée réaliser une
partie XXL mais mais plutôt d'avoir eu
ce relâchement coupable dans la deuxième
partie qui a laissé Samuel Sevian
revenir dans le match et Maxime coup de
tonnerre éliminé du Global cheescom
champion'sheep le joueur américain qui
mérite